Welcome to the 100th episode of SmartLess, I am your new host Bradley Cooper, the other guys of They Resigned, they just asked for too much money. Nah, I'm just kidding, these guys are going to be right up. Here's a new episode of SmartLess. Sean, I just wanted to ask you about... Happy 100th episode, by the way. Oh, thank you. This is the 100th episode?
欢迎收听第100期SmartLess，我是你们的新主持人布莱德利·库珀，另外那几个家伙辞职了，他们要的钱太多了。不，我开玩笑的，他们马上就来。这是新一期的SmartLess。肖恩，我刚才想问你关于……顺便说一句，第100期快乐。哦，谢谢。这是第100期吗？
Congrats fellas. This is the 100th episode. Happy 100. Wait a minute. This is our 100th episode? This is our 100th episode. I think it's 100. That's crazy.
恭喜伙计们。这是第100期。第100期快乐。等等。这是我们的第100期吗？这是我们的第100期。我想是100期。太疯狂了。
What is that? That's not... Isn't 50 as gold, right? What's the gold in that? 25 is... I guess there isn't a 100 anniversary because you'd be dead. 25 silver. Yeah, there's no 100.
那是什么？那不是……50周年是金婚，对吧？那100周年是什么？25周年是……我想没有100周年纪念，因为那时候你已经不在了。25周年是银婚。是的，没有100周年。
There's no 100th anniversary. Who's married for 100? Well, it would be platinum. I think it would be platinum, wouldn't it? Well, I think 75th is diamond. Okay. 75th is diamond. Okay.
没有100周年纪念。谁能结婚100年？嗯，那应该是白金婚。我想应该是白金婚，不是吗？嗯，我想75周年是钻石婚。好吧。75周年是钻石婚。好吧。
Let's look it up. Has anybody been married 100 years? Well, I know a couple who... It feels like 100. Oh, no. Is it you? What? No.
我们查一下。有人结婚100年了吗？嗯，我认识一对……感觉就像100年一样。哦，不。是你吗？什么？不。
How dare you? No. It says... I googled it. It says, what is the 100th anniversary color? It's purple. Ideas is... You could do a photo spread.
你怎么敢这么说？不。上面写着……我谷歌了一下。上面写着，100周年纪念的颜色是什么？是紫色。点子是……你可以做一个照片集。
You could do historical games. Wait, what site is that? Google. Google. Oh. It's not Google is not giving it to you. They've routed you to some other third party aftermarket site. Let's not get past the headline here, our own pathetic internal headline.
你可以做一些历史游戏。等等，那是哪个网站？谷歌。谷歌。哦。不是谷歌，不是谷歌给你的。他们把你导向了其他第三方售后网站。我们别纠结于标题了，我们自己那可怜的内部标题。
100. 100 means that we've done two years of shows, right? Can you believe that anybody would want to listen to us for 100? Let's take a second here and thank that single listener we have out there, Mr. or Mrs. Thank you for making it seem to yourself like listening to us three morons talk for an hour qualifies as entertainment, but please don't stop because we like doing it. Doesn't it feel like a week? It does feel like a week.
100。100意味着我们已经做了两年的节目，对吧？你能相信有人会想听我们聊100期吗？让我们花点时间感谢一下我们那位唯一的听众，先生或女士。感谢你让我们觉得听我们这三个白痴聊一个小时算是一种娱乐，但请不要停下来，因为我们喜欢这样做。这感觉像是一周吗？确实感觉像是一周。
You sounded like... But doesn't it seem like... Like Jiminy Glick? No, it doesn't seem like Jiminy Glick. We've talked to 100 people. JB, did you play golf today under 100th? No, I just woke up late and I couldn't wash my hair. I've even gone to...
你听起来像……但难道不像……像吉米尼·格里克吗？不，看起来不像吉米尼·格里克。我们已经和100个人聊过了。JB，你今天打高尔夫球打到100杆以下了吗？不，我只是起晚了，没能洗头。我甚至去过……
I'm on Amanda's computer. I don't have my glasses on. Walkers through. What's going on? If you could smell me right now. What are you going to cut the hair? Oh, my God. It's...
我在阿曼达的电脑上。我没戴眼镜。沃克穿过来了。怎么了？如果你现在能闻到我身上的味道。你要去剪头发吗？哦，天哪。这是……
I kind of love in the hair these days. I got to say the other day, I really loved that it was coming out every side of your visor. I don't. I don't like it. And why do I listen to my wife about the length of my hair? Can't I just keep it short and dorky and dumb and square and... No, don't worry.
我最近有点喜欢这头发。我得说前几天，我真的很喜欢它从你遮阳帽两边露出来的样子。我不喜欢。我不喜欢。为什么我要听我老婆关于头发长度的建议？我就不能留得短一点、呆一点、傻一点、方一点吗……不，别担心。
You look dumb and square a lot of the time. You're son of a... By the way, the thing about Jason is... I think everybody knows, Sean, you and everybody knows him knows that one truth actually doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. Well, what is it? It sounded like it might be a compliment.
你大部分时间看起来都很傻、很方。你这个……顺便说一句，关于杰森的事情是……我想大家都知道，肖恩，你和所有认识他的人都知道，那个事实其实并不重要。并不重要。嗯，那是什么？听起来像是个恭维。
So continue. No, it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. No, I'm not going to get it. Because it's not fair. We all know this, but we're not going to say it to him and forget it. It doesn't matter. All right.
所以继续。不，并不重要。并不重要。不，我不会说的。因为这不公平。我们都知道这一点，但我们不会对他说的，算了。并不重要。好吧。
Three, two. Well, you are talking about... Fucking hook, line and sinker. There is no thing. That was a test, but I was going to say, Sean, I just want to say this. I want to tell a true story that happened the last couple of days, and this is Jason. And I love him so much. We're playing golf against these guys.
三，二。嗯，你在谈论……该死，完全上钩了。根本没那回事。那是个测试，但我本来想说，肖恩，我只想说这个。我想讲一个过去几天发生的真实故事，这就是杰森。我太爱他了。我们正在和这些人打高尔夫球。
And if you understand golf, and if you're bored, go wash the dishes for a second or turn... Sean, not you. No, by the way, we're just trying to stay connected to the people, by the way. When we're out there playing golf, we're just trying to keep it... We're playing with randos. We're going out to the public course and we're just picking up a couple of randos and we're saying, come hit with us.
如果你懂高尔夫，如果你觉得无聊，去洗会儿碗或者转……肖恩，不是你。不，顺便说一句，我们只是想和大家保持联系。当我们出去打高尔夫时，我们只是想保持……我们和路人一起打。我们去公共球场，随便找几个路人，然后说，来和我们一起打吧。
That's fine. That's fine. We're playing against these guys and they're crushing us on the front nine. They're beating us. I'm all over the place. I'm playing terrible. Jason's not playing. He's pretty great, but he's not playing as normal, great.
那没关系。那没关系。我们和这些人比赛，他们在前九洞把我们打得落花流水。他们赢了我们。我到处乱打。我打得太烂了。杰森没在打。他很棒，但他没发挥出他平时的水平。
And so after nine holes, they're beating us. On the back nine, totally different. And you don't know these guys. We barely know. We sort of know one of the guys. We know one of the guys. The other guy, we don't know. On the back nine, we start to come back and there's one hole left and we're walking from
所以在九洞之后，他们赢了我们。在后九洞，完全不同了。你根本不认识这些人。我们几乎不认识。我们大概认识其中一个人。我们认识其中一个人。另一个人，我们不认识。在后九洞，我们开始反击，还剩一个洞，我们正从
the 17th green to the 18th tee and we have a chance to eradicate the loss and Jason goes all we got to do. They're up ahead of us. I don't speak like a dude from Bayone when I want to get down to business. What we got to do is we got to get a nice piece of study. Get some sausage. No, he says all we got to do is we got to win this hole. He goes, I'm telling you, man, if we beat these guys, they should kill themselves.
第17洞果岭走到第18洞发球台，我们有机会扭转败局，杰森说我们只需要。他们在我们前面。当我想谈正事时，我不会像个贝永人那样说话。我们要做的就是我们要弄点好东西。弄点香肠。不，他说我们要做的就是我们要赢下这个洞。他说，我告诉你，伙计，如果我们赢了这些人，他们应该自杀。
What is this? The karate kid? And I go kill them. I go, take your foot off the gas, man. It's Wednesday, OK? They should kill themselves. I was trying. I had to get myself up.
这是什么？《小子难缠》吗？我说杀了他们。我说，把脚从油门上拿开，伙计。今天是周三，好吗？他们应该自杀。我当时在努力。我得振作起来。
He went so psycho, Sean. It was. I believe it. It was crazy. That's where my wars are fought, you know? You take it really seriously. Listen, we've come, we're at a hundred episodes. I just want to just say this because this is the last time we're going to sit because
他变得太疯狂了，肖恩。确实。我相信。太疯狂了。那就是我战斗的地方，你知道吗？你把它看得太认真了。听着，我们已经到了100期了。我只想说这一点，因为这是我们最后一次坐在这里，因为
the next time we record an episode, we're not going to be able to say this. In four days, it's Will and it's birthday. Speaking of a hundred, Will and it's birthday. Oh, it's a century, you're a century years old. Oh, happy birthday. Yeah, happy. Love you. Sweet, sweet, Willie.
下次我们录制节目时，我们就不能说这个了。四天后，是威尔的生日。说到100，威尔的生日。哦，是一个世纪，你一百岁了。哦，生日快乐。是的，快乐。爱你。甜甜的，甜甜的威利。
Thank you. How old are you going to be? Let's go. I'm going to be 52. Don't make me Google it. I'm going to be 52. So we know that this is recorded before my birthday and very generously, our friend is having a nice birthday dinner for us tonight and the kids and everybody.
谢谢。你要多大了？来吧。我要52岁了。别让我去谷歌查。我要52岁了。所以我们知道这是在我生日之前录制的，而且非常慷慨的是，我们的朋友今晚要为我们和孩子们以及所有人准备一顿很棒的生日晚餐。
And I'm generously showing up. And I, too, am. And I'm so excited to see you guys. I know, I'm too. I haven't seen you guys in so long. I mean, no, because you were in Chicago and I've been in Atlanta. I've seen Jason, you know, when he suggested those guys kill themselves, but I'm really generally excited.
而且我慷慨地出席了。我也是。我太兴奋能见到你们了。我知道，我也是。我好久没见到你们了。我是说，不，因为你在芝加哥，我在亚特兰大。我见过杰森，你知道，当他建议那些人自杀的时候，但我真的很兴奋。
What do you hope to get for your birthday? Yeah. I mean, I know it doesn't really matter about gifts once you get past about 12. Oh, God. I don't even think about it. Are you looking for anything? No, I don't ever expect to get a gift. You think you're going to get anything from your boys?
你希望生日得到什么？是的。我是说，我知道一旦过了12岁，礼物就不重要了。哦，天哪。我甚至没想过。你在找什么吗？不，我从不指望得到礼物。你觉得你会从你儿子那里得到什么吗？
I hope they get like a nice picture or like a poem or something. They're able. They're both really good. They're really nice that way. I'm going to be redundant because I wrote you. I wrote you a poem. Let me, honestly, what are the odds of them writing you a poem? I don't know.
我希望他们能画张漂亮的画或者写首诗什么的。他们能做到。他们俩都很棒。他们在这方面真的很贴心。我要重复一遍，因为我给你写了。我给你写了一首诗。让我，老实说，他们给你写诗的几率是多少？我不知道。
I'm just really excited to, I don't know, just excited to see you guys and have all the people I love and around and, I don't know. Yeah. That'd be super fine. I'm going to write it tonight. That's going to be my goal is to get you to cry tonight, which might mean I might stand up and do a toast, which I can't, I hate doing it. I love it.
我只是真的很兴奋，我不知道，只是兴奋能见到你们，让我爱的人都在身边，我不知道。是的。那会非常棒。我今晚要写。我的目标就是让你今晚哭出来，这可能意味着我会站起来敬酒，我不能，我讨厌这样做。我喜欢。
Nothing makes me more nervous than getting a toast. That's why you got to do it. That's why you got to do it. Is it true? Yeah. I could give me anything in front of the camera or whatever is fine, but making a toast or speech in front of a bunch of people on stage, when we did the tour, in front of an auditorium full of people on stage with a spotlight is the most nerve wracking thing.
没有什么比敬酒更让我紧张的了。这就是为什么你必须去做。这就是为什么你必须去做。是真的吗？是的。在镜头前让我做什么都行，但在舞台上当着一群人的面敬酒或演讲，当我们巡演时，在满是观众的礼堂里，在聚光灯下，是最让人神经紧张的事情。
But you were great. You were great. You couldn't tell. You were great. But, you know, I mean, I've got, I've got acting skills. I know how to bury the. You just don't like it. But I just don't like it, but especially not a toast.
但你表现得很棒。你表现得很棒。你看不出来。你表现得很棒。但是，你知道，我是说，我有，我有表演技巧。我知道怎么掩饰。你只是不喜欢它。但我就是不喜欢，尤其是敬酒。
I just feel like such a beach bag, expecting people to stop what you're doing and listen to me as I hold up a glass. It's the most arrogant thing I've ever done. Nothing I love more. Nothing I love more. No, but it's nice. It's nice. We're going to do it tonight.
我只是觉得像个傻瓜，指望人们停下手中的事，听我举杯。这是我做过的最傲慢的事情。没有什么比这更让我喜欢的了。没有什么比这更让我喜欢的了。不，但这很好。这很好。我们今晚要做。
We're all going to toast each other. It's going to be. I mean, my toast is going to be here's to Jason's toast and then I'm going to force you to. Oh, and pass it on. That's nice. Jason, you just, you just don't, it's tough for you to, to connect on that emotional level. And I think that if you just connect to the feeling and forget what you have to say, nobody's judging you and just connect to the feeling for once, you imagine what a breakthrough
我们都要互相敬酒。这会是。我是说，我的敬酒词会是，为杰森的敬酒干杯，然后我会强迫你。哦，传下去。那很好。杰森，你只是，你只是，你很难在情感层面上建立联系。我认为如果你只是连接到那种感觉，忘记你要说什么，没人会评判你，只要连接到那种感觉一次，你能想象那会是多大的突破吗？
that would be. Guess what? That's what you're going to get tonight. We're going to reference this tonight and then I'm going to stumble my way through it. I can't wait. Pick me up. I am not going to break eye contact with you either. I am not breaking eye contact.
猜猜怎么着？这就是你今晚会得到的。我们今晚会提到这个，然后我会磕磕绊绊地完成它。我等不及了。接我吧。我也不会和你断开眼神交流的。我不会断开眼神交流。
No matter what, speaking of eye contact, our guest, an optimologist is someone, if you make eye contact, if you happen to get locked into this person's gaze, this is a hundredth episode guest. This is better. Let me say something. Well, this better be something that we've all locked. Better be good. This is somebody we've all locked gaze with real, not just us.
无论如何，说到眼神交流，我们的嘉宾，一位眼科医生，如果你进行眼神交流，如果你碰巧被锁在这个人的凝视中，这是第100期的嘉宾。这更好。让我说点什么。嗯，这最好是我们都锁定的东西。最好是好的。这是我们都曾与之锁定目光的人，不仅仅是我们。
The world has locked the gaze and he is locked in on the world. He has made a connection, a contact that is tough to be broken. But this is something that we've been in contact with for a long time. The three of us are friends with this person. This person is a friend of the show. This person is a friend of ours. This person has seven more Academy Award nominations than the three of us, which means that he has seven.
世界已经锁定了他的目光，他也锁定了世界。他建立了一种联系，一种难以打破的接触。但这正是我们长期以来一直保持联系的东西。我们三个是这个人的朋友。这个人是节目的朋友。这个人是我们的朋友。这个人比我们三个多七项奥斯卡提名，这意味着他有七项。
I don't know anyone that has seven, Academy Award. Seven nominations. I know this person. Four for acting and three for directing and all of the above. This is a person that we all adore. This is a person who's been part of our lives for a long time that we've been on a journey with for a long time. He takes my hair.
我不认识有七项奥斯卡提名的人。七项提名。我认识这个人。四项表演提名，三项导演提名，以及以上所有。这是一个我们都崇拜的人。这是一个长期以来一直是我们生活一部分的人，我们和他一起走过了一段很长的旅程。他拿走了我的头发。
He has single-handedly just absolutely done incredible things over the last 15 years, but he's always been an incredible person, but on top of it, he's just an incredible guy. I don't want to talk about his work accolades because I want to talk about how much we love this person. I can't wait to bring them in for our 100th episode I have brought our dear friend, Mr. Bradley Cooper. I've admired Will for so long, honestly, you're talking, I was getting so excited that you
他单枪匹马地在过去15年里做了绝对不可思议的事情，但他一直是一个不可思议的人，而且最重要的是，他只是一个不可思议的家伙。我不想谈论他的工作成就，因为我想谈谈我们有多爱这个人。我迫不及待地想让他参加我们的第100期节目，我带来了我们亲爱的朋友，布莱德利·库珀先生。我一直很钦佩威尔，老实说，你在说话，我太兴奋了，你
were talking about me. What a nice bait and switch, though. I can't believe he's talking about me, he's actually saying these things about me. We used to be like, we used to share an apartment, the best was like, does he ever even think about me? I love you. Do you remember the apartment? You guys all remember the apartment.
在谈论我。多好的诱饵和转换啊。我不敢相信他在谈论我，他竟然在说这些关于我的话。我们过去常常，我们过去合租一套公寓，最棒的是，他甚至会想到我吗？我爱你。你还记得那套公寓吗？你们都记得那套公寓。
I remember we used to play cards downstairs in that old apartment. What was the actor's name that lived below you? Ron Rifkin. Ron Rifkin. And his wife, Isla, lived in the front. Now, Bradley, you know, I thought this is, I would have never guessed because I thought we used all the favor you would give us by you making that cameo on the live version. I thought I used it up.
我记得我们过去在那间旧公寓楼下打牌。住在你们楼下的那个演员叫什么名字？罗恩·里夫金。罗恩·里夫金。他的妻子艾拉住在前面。现在，布莱德利，你知道，我想这是，我永远不会猜到，因为我以为我们用完了你给我们的所有恩惠，因为你在现场版里客串了。我以为我用完了。
So when Will texted me, I was so excited because I thought that you guys had no more interests. People don't know that you joined us on the tour socially backstage, we were all hanging out for a long time. It was so fucking fun and you came on only briefly. So you haven't really done an episode, so this is great. But now we get a full 60 minutes, although we have cut into your time a little bit. We've cut it, yeah. We always cut into people's time with our garbage, which is...
所以当威尔给我发短信时，我太兴奋了，因为我以为你们没兴趣了。人们不知道你在巡演期间在后台和我们社交，我们大家在一起玩了很长时间。太他妈有趣了，你只是短暂地出现了一下。所以你还没真正参加过一期节目，所以这太棒了。但现在我们有整整60分钟，尽管我们稍微占用了你的时间。我们占用了，是的。我们总是用我们的垃圾占用别人的时间，这……
No, that's the best part of the show. Let me start. Bradley, can I start? Bradley, what's your middle name? Oh. Oh, God. And then Sean's going to go color. I'm going to give a little history.
不，那是节目最棒的部分。让我开始。布莱德利，我可以开始吗？布莱德利，你的中间名是什么？哦。哦，天哪。然后肖恩要开始讲颜色了。我要讲一点历史。
Can I give a little history? Can I give a little history? Yeah, go history. Bradley, you go. Because for everybody that knows the show, you know, I've had the great fortune to know all of these guys separately for about 20 years each. Yeah, that's crazy. And each one of their circles, they have always been the funniest person in the room and everybody
我可以讲一点历史吗？我可以讲一点历史吗？是的，讲历史吧。布莱德利，你来。因为对于所有了解这个节目的人来说，你知道，我有幸在过去20年里分别认识了这些家伙。是的，那太疯狂了。在他们每个人的圈子里，他们一直都是房间里最有趣的人，每个人
knows it. And I'll go as far as to say that Will's probably always been the king of every room combined. That's right. Literally what everybody's always said. It's just... You can't be Will. You've...
都知道。我甚至可以说，威尔可能一直都是所有房间里的国王。没错。字面上每个人都这么说。这只是……你不能成为威尔。你……
Everyone's playing for the silver. Yeah. So for all these guys to be together, and I said this on stage too, but I finally, like what I've been able to be a benefactor of, now everybody gets to as well. And that's part of why it's so successful. But the other thing was, like, you have this way of talking, Jason, and the first, like, I don't know, 15 years I knew you, I was always like, oh, he's fucking with me. What's your middle name, Bradley?
每个人都在争夺银牌。是的。所以对于所有这些家伙在一起，我也在舞台上说过，但我终于，就像我能够成为受益者一样，现在每个人也都能受益了。这就是它如此成功的部分原因。但另一件事是，就像，你有一种说话方式，杰森，前，我不知道，我认识你的15年里，我总是想，哦，他在耍我。你的中间名是什么，布莱德利？
No, Bradley, what's your middle name? Like I give a fuck what your answer is. I'm just looking for a way to demolish you. So every time I'm like, oh, I don't know, Jason, it's Charlie, it's Charles Cooper based on my dad. Who died? Are you going to make fun of that? Well, you know, I do, I do, I do.
不，布莱德利，你的中间名是什么？好像我他妈在乎你的答案是什么。我只是在找一种摧毁你的方法。所以每次我都想，哦，我不知道，杰森，是查理，是查尔斯·库珀，以我父亲的名字命名。他去世了？你要拿那个开玩笑吗？嗯，你知道，我做，我做，我做。
Are you going to hit me there, Jason? I do admit that I sound and act a lot shittier than I really am. Now, I'm not going to make this up without me. That is true. By the way, can I say that? So that was the first 15 years. Yeah. I'd say the last five years I've come to realize that Jason is a really kind of a wonderful
你要在那儿打我吗，杰森？我确实承认我听起来和表现得比我实际要糟糕得多。现在，我不会在没有我的情况下编造这个。那是真的。顺便说一句，我可以这么说吗？所以那是前15年。是的。我想过去五年我开始意识到杰森其实是一个非常美好的人。
human being. Yeah. I'm not the ass who you thought I was. Or that everybody thinks I am. But there is something about the tone, the prosody one could say of the way you speak. I'm just... I'm... I see...
是的。我不是你以为的那个混蛋。或者大家以为的那样。但你的语气，或者说你说话的韵律，确实有些东西。我只是……我……我看到……
Will and I... You could get five amens. You can get a shit girl. Oh, shit. Will and I saw some time on the documentary behind the scene special that we shot of this tour thing. Yeah, Bradley. You know when Sam was shooting that thing, right?
威尔和我……你可以得到五个阿门。你可以得到一个该死的女孩。哦，该死。威尔和我在这场巡演的幕后纪录片特辑中看到了一些时间。是的，布莱德利。你知道萨姆在拍那个东西的时候，对吧？
Yeah, of course. Yeah. And so Will and I saw a couple hours of it and I said to Will yesterday, right before I said that golfers should kill themselves, that I said, I think I'm just such an asshole on that thing. Don't I seem like a real... He's like, no, man, me. I think I'm just a crabby...
是的，当然。是的。所以威尔和我看了几个小时，我昨天对威尔说，就在我说高尔夫球手应该自杀之前，我说，我觉得我在那东西里真是个混蛋。我不看起来像个真正的……他就像，不，伙计，我。我觉得我只是个暴躁的……
By the way, and this is why you were like, Sean, why didn't you come? I didn't want to go through this. Like I don't want to like... Well, let me tell you something, son, Sean. You couldn't be sweeter. You couldn't be nicer. You look... You come off looking like...
顺便说一句，这就是为什么你会说，肖恩，你为什么没来？我不想经历这个。就像我不想……嗯，让我告诉你一件事，肖恩。你再甜美不过了。你再好不过了。你看起来……你看起来像……
When you're the prick... Yeah. You're the mother. Yeah. You're so... You're happy, go lucky. Hey, guys. I don't mind.
当你是个混蛋时……是的。你是那个母亲。是的。你太……你快乐，随遇而安。嘿，伙计们。我不介意。
Turn the cameras off. First of all, the first 20 minutes... We talk about food. Oh, my God, it's hilarious. It's nothing but food. And what we kept in was, because Jason keeps bringing up, Bradley, you love this, Sam kept in was me finally going to Jason, you're going to watch this, and you're going to see how obsessed with food you are, and you're going to be so ashamed at your fucking neurosis.
关掉摄像机。首先，前20分钟……我们谈论食物。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。全是食物。我们保留下来的是，因为杰森一直在提，布莱德利，你喜欢这个，萨姆保留下来的是我终于对杰森说，你会看这个，你会看到你对食物有多痴迷，你会为你那该死的神经质感到羞耻。
Okay. It's so true, though. It's not true, but you're not an asshole. I'm an asshole. Because anytime anybody says anything, I just like hammer them. But wait a minute. I hope everybody knows that we all love each other, and that's why we can get after each other like brothers.
好吧。但这太真实了。这不是真的，但你不是混蛋。我是混蛋。因为每当有人说什么，我就像锤他们一样。但等等。我希望每个人都知道我们都爱彼此，这就是为什么我们可以像兄弟一样互相攻击。
Of course. Bradley, you're obsessed with food. Bradley? Jason's not the only one. Oh, look who's here. It's Bradley. Right? Because you are...
当然。布莱德利，你对食物很痴迷。布莱德利？杰森不是唯一一个。哦，看谁来了。是布莱德利。对吧？因为你是……
Your body is insane. What? My body. Your body is insane. You're always in such fucking great shape, always. Not Sean. That is just incorrect. Oh, my God.
你的身体太疯狂了。什么？我的身体。你的身体太疯狂了。你总是保持着那么好的身材，总是。不是肖恩。那是不正确的。哦，天哪。
That is an incorrect statement. No, it's not. It's pretty close to true. I literally was just at the rehearsal today with all these dancers, because we're doing this part of the movie. I'm about to start a movie, so we're in prep. Bradley's playing Leonard Bernstein, and it's going to be great. I was watching the playback, and I was like, I look like a fucking lion, like a wrestler
那是一个不正确的陈述。不，不是。这非常接近事实。我今天真的在和所有这些舞者排练，因为我们正在拍电影的这一部分。我正要开始拍一部电影，所以我们在准备。布莱德利在扮演伦纳德·伯恩斯坦，这会很棒。我在看回放，我想，我看起来像个该死的狮子，像个摔跤手
with my shoulders. I was like, dude, what are we going to do? It's like, all these beautiful bodies, this is fucking me, like dancing like I got fucking like lead on my feet. But by the way, you are like, you know, I thought, you don't see somebody who's like super fucking talented, super fucking nice, super fucking handsome, and then you see them do another thing really well, and you're like, oh my God, life's not fair. Every time you dance on something, it's incredible.
带着我的肩膀。我想，伙计，我们要怎么办？就像，所有这些美丽的身体，这是该死的我，跳舞就像我脚上带着铅一样。但顺便说一句，你就像，你知道，我想，你没见过一个超级有才华、超级好、超级帅的人，然后你看到他们做另一件事也做得很好，你会想，哦，天哪，生活不公平。每次你跳舞，都不可思议。
Like I can't. I actually do love to dance. That was like the one thing bar mitzvahs, I couldn't wait for the bar mitzvah, that was all my time. For women to get women's attention. Wait till they get a load of me. I'm like getting number like, let's get Shabbat Shalom. Shabbat Shalom.
就像我不能。我其实真的很喜欢跳舞。那是唯一的一件事，犹太成人礼，我等不及犹太成人礼了，那是我所有的时光。为了让女性关注女性。等着瞧吧。我就像得到数字一样，让我们安息日快乐。安息日快乐。
Shabbat Shalom. Good Yantuff. Good Yantuff. Good Yantuff. But I will say this. I mean, Bradley, dancing or whatever it is, when you did Star is Born, I had this like, Bradley and I had this surreal moment years ago. That was amazing.
安息日快乐。节日快乐。节日快乐。节日快乐。但我会说这个。我是说，布莱德利，跳舞或者其他什么，当你拍《一个明星的诞生》时，我和布莱德利几年前有过这种超现实的时刻。那太棒了。
Remember that? I was at Cinemacon. Cinemacon. And I got to introduce Bradley Cummins. He was showing a trailer for his movie, and he just directed this huge and written this and in this movie and produced, and we stood there on the stage with the whole audience and watched it. And it was so surreal.
记得吗？我在电影博览会。电影博览会。我有幸介绍了布莱德利·库珀。他正在展示他电影的预告片，他刚刚导演了这部巨大的电影，并写了这部电影，并制作了这部电影，我们站在舞台上和整个观众一起看了它。这太超现实了。
We both had tears in our eyes. Yeah, we were both crying. It was great. And you had to host this whole thing, which was nuts, and you had this like, did you have a white suit on? Am I crazy? Or was like, it was like, you had like this like, like really, like this, like, really cool suit on, and you were sweating, like you were like, I mean, you were working your
我们俩眼里都有泪水。是的，我们俩都在哭。太棒了。你必须主持整个事情，这太疯狂了，你当时有，你穿了一套白西装吗？我疯了吗？还是就像，就像，你穿了一套非常，非常酷的西装，你在出汗，就像你就像，我是说，你在努力
ass off, dude. Yeah. Yeah. I was working my ass off. It was fucking crazy. It was like Elvis in Vegas. Like, literally, it felt like Vegas, because that Cinemacon stadium is very vertical. Remember?
工作，伙计。是的。是的。我在努力工作。这太他妈疯狂了。就像拉斯维加斯的猫王。就像，字面上，感觉就像拉斯维加斯，因为那个电影博览会体育场非常垂直。记得吗？
Yeah. It's like, it's not, there's not much depth. It feels like you're in the Thunderdome. I looked like I had just eaten a million fry banana sandwiches, too. I looked so huge at the time. I was a dump. What? Tan is fucked, too.
是的。就像，它不是，没有太多深度。感觉就像你在雷霆穹顶。我看起来也像刚吃了上百万个炸香蕉三明治。我当时看起来太巨大了。我是一个垃圾。什么？晒黑也搞砸了。
I remember that. Was Leonard Bernstein dancing in this movie? No. Yeah. Yes. Well, I don't want to give it, but there is this sort of magical moment. But tell people, I don't know if you heard me, Bradley's right written, directed and starring again in a movie.
我记得那个。伦纳德·伯恩斯坦在这部电影里跳舞吗？不。是的。是的。嗯，我不想剧透，但有一种神奇的时刻。但告诉人们，我不知道你是否听到了，布莱德利再次编写、导演并主演了一部电影。
This time he's playing Leonard Bernstein, which is crazy. It's a movie about marriage. It's not a biopic, but yes, yeah, I do play Leonard Bernstein. Yeah. Yeah. We started shooting May 21st. We just, I just got back from Massachusetts yesterday. We drove there.
这次他扮演伦纳德·伯恩斯坦，这太疯狂了。这是一部关于婚姻的电影，不是传记片，但是的，是的，我确实扮演伦纳德·伯恩斯坦。是的。是的。我们5月21日开始拍摄。我们刚刚，我昨天刚从马萨诸塞州回来。我们开车去的。
That's so exciting. I can't wait. You know, it's been four and a half years in the making, and I'm, I feel very grateful. I feel so grateful. This has been such a labor of love for you, man, and you have put in the work and you've gone through so many stages of shooting pieces and developing it and writing it and researching it and learning. And Jason was kind enough to sit through a lot of the test proofs that I showed you,
太令人兴奋了。我等不及了。你知道，这花了四年半的时间，我，我感到非常感激。我感到非常感激。这对你来说真是爱的结晶，伙计，你付出了努力，你经历了这么多拍摄片段、开发它、编写它、研究它和学习它的阶段。杰森很友善地坐下来看完了我给你看的很多测试样片，
remember? And that was one of the times as I walked back in my car, I'm like, oh, he's just ripping me apart. No. Are you out of your mind? So you're trying to pretend that I was like giving him that? I would sit, I could sit there for 40 years and watch what you'd talk about. You know how I'd dork out on all that stuff, but I'm so like, you could have picked anything
记得吗？那是其中一次，当我走回车里时，我想，哦，他只是在把我撕成碎片。不。你疯了吗？所以你试图假装我是在给他那个？我可以坐在这里40年，看着你谈论的东西。你知道我怎么对所有那些东西着迷，但我太，你可以选择任何东西
to do, A, with your first film. You could have taken a much smaller bite. But no, the huge scope and the scale of that thing with a big, huge co-star and a remake of like a beloved, and now you're going to move into this epic about a beloved American icon and going into like make a press, a little bit of prosthetics, maybe or like, no, a lot. I mean, he's 25 to, to, to at least 69. It's just, you're not phoning this in.
去做，A，你的第一部电影。你可以咬下一小口。但不，那东西的巨大范围和规模，有一个巨大的联合主演和一部心爱作品的翻拍，现在你要进入这个关于一位心爱的美国偶像的史诗，并进入制作，一点点假体，也许或者像，不，很多。我是说，他从25岁到，到，到至少69岁。你不是在敷衍了事。
I'm no different than all of you. I mean, Sean, Sean, you're just Oscar Levant. I mean, you've created this whole entire world, Jason and Will, you've forged your own path that no one could even like compare. So everybody's done what they love. Yeah. It's just the truth. I don't know if I could play below 30 anymore.
我和你们所有人没什么不同。我是说，肖恩，肖恩，你就是奥斯卡·黎凡特。我是说，你创造了整个世界，杰森和威尔，你们开辟了自己的道路，没人能比得上。所以每个人都做了他们喜欢的事。是的。这只是事实。我不知道我是否还能演30岁以下的角色。
I don't even know. You need the prosthetics. Yeah. Probably to below 30. If I had to dip below 30, probably. I said to Bradley, because Bradley's playing Leonard Bernstein and he's gay, well, part of his life, he was gay. And I said, you're going to be making out with two, do you see what I'm saying?
我甚至不知道。你需要假体。是的。可能到30岁以下。如果我必须降到30岁以下，可能。我对布莱德利说，因为布莱德利在扮演伦纳德·伯恩斯坦，他是同性恋，嗯，他生活的一部分，他是同性恋。我说，你要和两个，你明白我在说什么吗？
Just the bottom part or? There's a... We're holding for laugh and rejoining. Which part? You waited. I said, I said, you're going to be making... You waited. He just like, bam.
只是下半部分还是？有一个……我们暂停笑声并重新加入。哪一部分？你等了。我说，我说，你要和……你等了。他就像，砰。
I'm going to stay back here in the five yard line. I could see it. My man's going to get open. Okay. Okay. Part of it. Do you have to make out with dudes in the movie and everything? And he said, yeah.
我要留在五码线后面。我能看到它。我的伙计会打开局面的。好吧。好吧。它的一部分。你必须在电影里和男人亲热吗？他说，是的。
And I go, look, I can run lines with you if you want. Was there nothing that was right for Sean in the film? I mean... Yeah. You know who's in the movie, Sean? Sean, you know who he is. Who's in the movie? Scott Ellis, huge part.
我说，看，如果你想的话，我可以和你对台词。电影里没有什么适合肖恩的角色吗？我是说……是的。你知道谁在电影里吗，肖恩？肖恩，你知道他是谁。谁在电影里？斯科特·埃利斯，巨大的角色。
No way. You're joking. Yeah. Scott Ellis, the director of theater on the Broadway. No way. Yeah. He was perfect with this role. I asked him to do it.
不可能。你在开玩笑。是的。斯科特·埃利斯，百老汇的戏剧导演。不可能。是的。他非常适合这个角色。我请他做了。
He said, yes, we just closed the deal today. I'm so excited. That's so exciting. That's really exciting. That's great. That's cool. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
他说，是的，我们今天刚达成协议。我太兴奋了。太令人兴奋了。这真的很令人兴奋。太棒了。这很酷。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
I was going to go back to something Jason said about choosing a star. I want to get... I thank you for talking about me, but I do just... I just feel like I want to educate the audience about you guys. So let me know what you've done. No, no, no. They're so sick and tired of us, Brad. I don't think...
我本来想回到杰森说的关于选择明星的事情。我想得到……我感谢你谈论我，但我确实只是……我只是觉得我想让观众了解你们。所以让我知道你们做了什么。不，不，不。他们对我们感到厌烦了，布拉德。我不认为……
I don't like this stuff about the kids and other stuff, but like... Guess what? I didn't want to click on this. Said, oh, Bradley. That's a Bradley episode. We want to listen to this. Okay. It's all about you right now.
我不喜欢这些关于孩子和其他东西的事情，但就像……猜猜怎么着？我不想点击这个。说，哦，布莱德利。那是布莱德利的一期。我们想听这个。好吧。现在全是关于你的。
Fucks. Bradley has nine nominations. I fucked up. Whoa. Academy award nominations? Yeah, nine, motherfucker. What, did you just finally click on Wikipedia? Yeah, I just...
该死。布莱德利有九项提名。我搞砸了。哇。奥斯卡提名？是的，九项，混蛋。什么，你刚终于点击了维基百科？是的，我刚……
So I was at this party. I was at this party. I mean, you know... I mean, I know Will's like this. You know, I never forget anything anybody mean has ever said, right? It's like cataloged. I can tell. I know exactly where I was.
所以我当时在那个派对上。我当时在那个派对上。我是说，你知道……我是说，我知道威尔是这样的。你知道，我永远不会忘记任何人说过任何刻薄的话，对吧？就像被编目了一样。我能说出来。我知道我当时在哪里。
What are you talking about? You know, I challenged the verbiage, the sentence structure. I'm like, no, bro. That's not what you said. I never forget. I was like... You know, the CAA party like four years ago, I don't remember. At that time, it was like seven nominations, which is crazy.
你在说什么？你知道，我挑战了措辞，句子结构。我就像，不，兄弟。那不是你说的。我永远不会忘记。我当时就像……你知道，四年前的CAA派对，我不记得了。那时，它有七项提名，这太疯狂了。
It's nuts. And everybody's like, huh? It's crazy. But this director guy, I'm standing next to a woman who's a dear friend who's an actress and he goes, how many do you have? And I was like, oh, yeah, I have seven. How many do you have? Three.
太疯狂了。每个人都像，哈？太疯狂了。但这个导演，我站在一个亲爱的朋友旁边，她是一位女演员，他问，你有多少项？我当时就像，哦，是的，我有七项。你有多少项？三项。
What world are we living in where you have seven nominations? What, she's only got three. What is wrong that you... And I remember I was like, I fucking hate this business. No way. Oh, I never forget it. I remember, I'm looking. I'm like, bro, why are you such an asshole?
我们生活在什么世界里，你有七项提名？什么，她只有三项。你有什么问题……我记得我当时就像，我他妈讨厌这个行业。不可能。哦，我永远不会忘记。我记得，我在看。我就像，兄弟，你为什么这么混蛋？
I would never fucking forget that. Don't fuck yourself. I would make it a point to fucking crush that person. And then the first time I was nominated, I never forget this. I'm at that same party, this 2011, nominated with Daniel Day fucking Lewis, right? It was crazy. And Denzel Washington. I couldn't believe it, right?
我永远不会他妈的忘记那个。别他妈搞砸了。我会专门去他妈的摧毁那个人。然后我第一次被提名时，我永远不会忘记这个。我在同一个派对上，这是2011年，和丹尼尔·戴·刘易斯一起被提名，对吧？太疯狂了。还有丹泽尔·华盛顿。我不敢相信，对吧？
I'm like levitating and this like hero, female actress that I didn't know at all comes up to me. She goes, I think, well, you know this story. She's like, I saw your movie. You deserve the nom. Woof. I was like, what? I'm sorry.
我像在漂浮，这个像英雄一样的女演员，我根本不认识，走过来。她说，我想，嗯，你知道这个故事。她就像，我看了你的电影。你配得上提名。呜。我当时就像，什么？对不起。
What? The nom. And then like 10, 20 minutes later, I'm not kidding. I passed her like going to the bathroom and she like, and she mouths it. The nom. Wait, why was she trying to keep you down? I mean, like, don't win. You're never going to win.
什么？提名。然后像10、20分钟后，我没开玩笑。我经过她去洗手间，她就像，她用嘴型说了。提名。等等，为什么她试图打压你？我是说，就像，别赢。你永远不会赢。
Why was she trying to keep you down? I don't know, dude. But I remember like, what the fuck is this town? Because people are fucked up, man, because it's all, most of the time when you encounter people, I would say like 80% of interactions have to do with them. It's got nothing to do with you. You know what? You know what?
为什么她试图打压你？我不知道，伙计。但我记得就像，这他妈是什么镇？因为人们都他妈的搞砸了，伙计，因为这全是，大多数时候当你遇到人时，我会说80%的互动与他们有关。这和你没关系。你知道吗？你知道吗？
You're 100% right. Well, anytime anybody says anything negative, it's about their self-hatred. But could you imagine saying that to somebody? I mean, like, I mean, no. You've got to be fucked up to do that. No? I mean, here's what I'm going to push, but here's what I'm going to push back, Jason. It's kind of what you were saying before about feeling like you're an asshole.
你是100%正确的。嗯，每当有人说负面的话时，都是关于他们的自我厌恶。但你能想象对某人说那样的话吗？我是说，我是说，不。你得他妈的搞砸了才能那样做。不？我是说，这是我要推的，但这是我要反驳的，杰森。这有点像你之前说的感觉自己是个混蛋。
None of us in here would ever actually say something like that. I will bust some of these balls. Well, funny though, Sean, 2012, we were at... Oh, boy. Oh, no. Let's play the tape. Funny you should say that well. Thank you.
我们这里没有人会真的说那样的话。我会打破一些这些球。嗯，有趣的是，肖恩，2012年，我们在……哦，男孩。哦，不。让我们播放录音。有趣的是你应该说那个威尔。谢谢。
We were at Victor Garber's on Sunset Plaza. It was 8.30. We just had the tuna. I'm trying to go, this smells like your career. Although I will say, coming up in like 1999, 2000, and the comedians that were very popular back then, mean humor was the thing. And being an insecure person, I was like, and I knew because of Amy, I got to know Will and all that circle, and then doing wedding crashers got to know those good, right?
我们在日落广场的维克多·加伯家。那是8点30分。我们刚吃了金枪鱼。我试图去，这闻起来像你的职业生涯。虽然我会说，在1999年、2000年左右，当时非常流行的喜剧演员，刻薄的幽默是主流。作为一个不安全感的人，我当时就像，而且我知道因为艾米，我认识了威尔和那个圈子，然后拍《婚礼傲客》认识了那些好人，对吧？
So just around and seeing like, oh, and I remember there was a good year where all I did was try to access mean humor only out of insecurity in hopes that people would think I'm funny. And I still remember doing this like TV show. It's so embarrassing and like really hurting people's feelings, only trying to mimic people that I thought were funny. And Will, do you remember this? And I'll never forget, man.
所以只是到处看看，就像，哦，我记得有一个好年头，我所做的只是试图接触刻薄的幽默，仅仅是因为不安全感，希望人们会认为我很有趣。我仍然记得做这个电视节目。太尴尬了，真的伤害了人们的感情，只是试图模仿我认为有趣的人。威尔，你记得这个吗？我永远不会忘记，伙计。
We were living next to each other and Will came into where I was living. And he's like, hey man, we had dinner the night before, I know you're not supposed to cry on this show, sorry. This is pretty emotional. I'm not crying. I'm not crying. You're crying. I'm not crying.
我们住在一起，威尔走进我住的地方。他就像，嘿伙计，我们前一天晚上吃了晚饭，我知道你不应该在这个节目上哭，抱歉。这太情绪化了。我没哭。我没哭。你在哭。我没哭。
You're crying. No, but I'll never forget it because Will, who can be mean, but there's no ill Will. It's just like, if you know each other, you feel safe the way we do. But I didn't know Will that well then. And he was like, hey man, do you remember we had dinner the other night? And he goes, how'd you think that went? And I was like, and I remember being at the dinner thinking I was so funny. And I thought these two guys who were my heroes were so, thought that I was so funny.
你在哭。不，但我永远不会忘记它，因为威尔，他可以很刻薄，但没有恶意。这就像，如果你认识彼此，你就会感到安全，就像我们这样。但我当时不太了解威尔。他就像，嘿伙计，你记得我们前几天晚上吃了晚饭吗？他说，你觉得那次怎么样？我当时就像，我记得在晚饭时认为我很有趣。我以为这两个是我的英雄的家伙，认为我很有趣。
I don't know if you remember this, Will, and you're like, I was like, oh, I thought it was great. I thought I was killing it. Hey man, you were, and Will, I'm not telling you, you were a real asshole, man. You were a real asshole. And I was like, what? He's like, yeah. And by the way, have your dogs gone out to the bathroom?
我不知道你是否记得这个，威尔，你就像，我当时就像，哦，我觉得很棒。我觉得我表现得很好。嘿伙计，你表现得很好，威尔，我不是告诉你，你真是个混蛋，伙计。你真是个混蛋。我当时就像，什么？他就像，是的。顺便说一句，你的狗去洗手间了吗？
And I was like, what? What time is it? It's four o'clock. Oh no. I think they have to go to the bathroom. They're literally standing by the door. And that was like the first time I ever realized I had a problem with drugs and alcohol. And it was Will saying that to me.
我当时就像，什么？几点了？四点钟。哦，不。我想它们得去洗手间了。它们正站在门口。那是我第一次意识到我有毒品和酒精问题。是威尔对我说的。
And I'll just never forget it. And I was like, oh, the guy that I think is doing mean humor is telling me like truth about that. And it was like, it changed my entire life. And that moment was when I stopped pursuing this sort of mean humor thing. Wow. Because I heard, yeah, I'll never forget. Do you remember that, Will?
我永远不会忘记它。我当时就像，哦，那个我认为在做刻薄幽默的家伙正在告诉我关于那个的真相。这就像，它改变了我的一生。那一刻是我停止追求这种刻薄幽默的时候。哇。因为我听到了，是的，我永远不会忘记。你记得那个吗，威尔？
I do remember that, yeah. Wow. Wow. Thanks for sharing that, Bradley. That's amazing. And Bradley, was it because you were trying to quote, fit in and that's how you set this up? Yeah, of course.
我确实记得那个，是的。哇。哇。谢谢你的分享，布莱德利。太棒了。布莱德利，是因为你试图引用，融入其中，这就是你设置这个的方式吗？是的，当然。
I mean, zero self-esteem of trying, you know, zero and thinking like, oh, here's something like my brain works fast. Oh, I can be mean to people, right? If I'm like finding the holes and I can figure out. And then you realize that it's not mean. It's just a type of humor. It's a sense of comedy. Kind of like Don Rickles was the king of insults.
我是说，零自尊，试图，你知道，零，并认为就像，哦，这是某种像我的大脑工作很快的东西。哦，我可以对人刻薄，对吧？如果我像找到漏洞，我能弄清楚。然后你意识到那并不刻薄。这只是一种幽默。这是一种喜剧感。就像唐·里克斯是侮辱之王。
Well, actually, I would argue that like, I mean, it's tricky. That's a tricky conversation. But I didn't, I was so starving that it didn't matter that I was hurting people. I didn't even think that I was, because I didn't think I was powerful enough to hurt anybody anyway. So I never thought it was really hurting anybody because how could I if I'm worthless, right? So there was the sort of the pre of that, if you don't. So we had another friend and you and I had done not long before that we'd both weirdly
嗯，实际上，我会争辩说，我是说，这很棘手。这是一个棘手的对话。但我没有，我当时太饿了，以至于我伤害了别人也无所谓。我甚至没想过我在伤害，因为我不认为我足够强大到能伤害任何人。所以我从没想过它真的在伤害任何人，因为如果我是无价值的，我怎么能呢，对吧？所以如果你不这样做，就有那种预设。所以我们还有另一个朋友，你和我在这之前不久都奇怪地
just randomly had to do a photo shoot at the same studio. Do you remember that? I forget what it was for, but anyway, and you were, there were a bunch of other people that were doing it in different stages in Hollywood, like on Formosa or something. And you were kind of going through that stage where you were just being very aggressive at that, and, you know, and you were funny, but you were also like sometimes like really hardcore and it was like, whoa, man. And I remember thinking, and then that night was kind of that moment when I was like, and
当时刚好在同一个摄影棚拍照片。你还记得吗？我不记得是为了什么，但总之，当时好莱坞还有其他人在不同的摄影棚里拍摄，比如在福尔摩沙（Formosa）那边。你当时正处于那种状态，表现得非常有侵略性，你知道的，你很有趣，但有时又表现得非常强硬，当时我就觉得，哇，伙计。我记得当时我在想，那天晚上就是那一刻，我心想，而且
the truth was, I remember at that time being at that, at that stage and this buddy was there saying like, wow, I feel really bad, but he's been coming on really strong. And I go, I think that it's okay. I think he's just trying to fuck around and it's okay. And then that happened with our other friend. And I just remember thinking, that's always a tricky thing, but I just remember thinking, you know, I love you and wanted you to be okay, you know what I mean? And I knew that you weren't feeling great about stuff.
事实是，我记得当时我处于那个阶段，那个哥们也在场，他说，哇，我感觉真的很糟糕，但他表现得太强势了。我说，我觉得没关系。我觉得他只是想胡闹一下，没事的。后来我们另一个朋友也发生了类似的事。我只记得当时在想，这总是一件棘手的事情，但我只记得我在想，你知道，我爱你，希望你一切都好，你明白我的意思吗？我知道你当时对很多事情感觉不太好。
Was that the moment, Bradley, that you just described or was there something more, even more significant that made you, that clicked in your brain that says, oh, shit, I really have to look at myself and maybe take a left turn. Well, I was so, I mean, I was so lost. I was so lost. And I was, you had a weird, you had a, and I was addicted to cocaine, you know, that was the other thing. And you injured your, remember you injured your leg.
布拉德利，那是你刚才描述的那个时刻吗？还是有更重要的事情，让你脑子里突然“叮”的一声，意识到，哦，该死，我真的得审视一下自己，也许该换个方向了。嗯，我当时太……我是说，我太迷茫了。我太迷茫了。而且，你当时有一种奇怪的……我当时对可卡因上瘾，你知道，那是另一回事。而且你受伤了，记得吗，你伤了腿。
Oh yeah. I was seven Michaelis tendon right after I got fired slash quit alias. And that, you know, it was, it was, it was, you know, But you know, the people say, you know, success will show you who you are, you know, that will bring out, it'll surface who you are because what it triggers is usually a pretty permissive environment around you. So you know, you don't, you can drop whatever artifice you've been using here to for, right? So what's great about your incredible level of success is that it did the opposite of
哦，是的。我在被《双面女间谍》（Alias）解雇或辞职后不久就伤了跟腱。那，你知道，那真是……但你知道，人们常说，成功会让你看清自己，你知道，它会让你显露本性，因为它触发的通常是你周围一个相当放纵的环境。所以你知道，你不需要再继续使用你之前使用的任何伪装了，对吧？所以你令人难以置信的成功之处在于，它恰恰相反，
what is kind of traditional and cliche in this business where, you know, the more famous and rich you are, the bigger prick you are, it allowed you to be as kind and vulnerable and human as you innately are with no fear of that being misinterpreted. I've talked about before about how Ron Howard is sort of this great North Star for me with that. Like he doesn't ever worry about anybody thinking that he's too eager to talk to them or too eager for a job when he walks into a room all smiles and chatty, you know, because he doesn't need it.
与这个行业中那种传统且陈词滥调的情况不同，你知道，你越出名、越富有，你就越是个混蛋，但它反而让你能够像你天生那样善良、脆弱和人性化，而不必担心被误解。我之前谈到过罗恩·霍华德（Ron Howard），他对我来说就像是一颗伟大的北极星。比如，他从不担心别人会认为他太急于和他们交谈，或者太渴望得到一份工作，当他满脸笑容、健谈地走进房间时，你知道，因为他不需要这些。
You are the same way. And it's allowed you to be what is universally agreed upon as far as your reputation goes, your attention to your coworkers, irrespective of the position that they hold on the set. It's just, I think it's an incredibly admirable thing and you can't hide from that any longer. But I will say this, you know, I did have the benefit of that happening when I was 29 and I definitely would not, I mean, I thought I was, I thought I made it when I got a Wendy's commercial and I called my dad saying, you know, I'm in a hotel that has a window that opens like and it's paying for it, you know, so I mean, I mean, in terms of the made it
你也是一样。这让你能够保持大家公认的声誉，你对同事的关注，无论他们在片场担任什么职位。我认为这真是一件令人钦佩的事情，你再也无法隐藏这一点了。但我得说，你知道，我确实受益于我在29岁时就经历了这一切，我绝对不会……我是说，我以为我成功了，当我接到一个温蒂汉堡（Wendy's）的广告时，我打电话给我爸说，你知道，我住的酒店窗户能打开，而且还有人付钱，你知道，所以我是说，就“成功”这件事而言，
thing, you know, that's when I made it. But I definitely did not feel moving to Los Angeles for alias feeling like I was back in high school, couldn't get in any clubs, like no girls want to really look at me. Like it was like, what? I mean, I totally depressed, you know, so, so at 29, it wasn't till really hangover. I was 36 when I did the hangover. So I got to go through all of those things before fame even played into my, my existence on a daily level.
你知道，那就是我成功的时候。但我绝对没有那种感觉，搬到洛杉矶拍《双面女间谍》时，感觉就像回到了高中，进不去任何俱乐部，没有女孩想看我一眼。就像是，什么？我是说，我完全抑郁了，你知道，所以，在29岁时，直到《宿醉》（Hangover）才真正……我拍《宿醉》时36岁。所以我必须在名气真正影响我的日常生活之前，经历所有这些事情。
So all that happened before any of that, which makes you so appreciative of where you are. Yeah. And then it's just like, that's like, oh, it is, it's an element has nothing to do with anything. And so that's what I was going to say, Jason, because Jason has made that point before, but I would, I agree with Bradley, Bradley, you actually went through this metamorphosis before hangover, like you said, before all this stuff and having those realizations and having that change allowed you, that's what opened you up and allowed you to be you and
所以这一切都发生在那之前，这让你非常感激你现在的处境。是的。然后就像是，那只是……哦，它是一个元素，与任何事情都无关。所以我正想说这个，杰森，因为杰森之前也提出过这一点，但我同意布拉德利的观点，布拉德利，你实际上在《宿醉》之前就经历了这种蜕变，就像你说的，在所有这些事情发生之前，拥有那些顿悟并做出改变，这让你敞开了心扉，让你能够成为你自己，并且
allowed you to be. It's true. What? What? When you say that, what do you mean? Just going through all those things. I, again, you know, still working on self-esteem up until, you know, like a year ago and still do, but like, but I definitely made major breakthroughs, you know, 29 to 34, 2, 3, 34, where at least
让你能够成为。这是真的。什么？什么？当你这么说时，你是什么意思？就是经历所有那些事情。我，再说一次，你知道，直到一年前我还在努力提升自尊，现在依然如此，但是，我确实取得了重大突破，你知道，29岁到34岁，2、3、34岁，至少
I was able to like stand in front of somebody and breathe and listen and talk and, yeah. By touching bottom, was touching bottom one of the things that allowed you to kind of push off? Oh, I mean, that was the, of course, that's the game Scotty and I play. Touching bottoms. Yeah. I was going to say, Sean, touching bottoms for you. That was different than that.
我能够站在某人面前，呼吸、倾听和交谈，是的。通过触底反弹，触底反弹是让你能够重新出发的原因之一吗？哦，我是说，那当然是斯科蒂和我玩的游戏。触底反弹。是的。我正想说，肖恩，对你来说触底反弹。那和那个不一样。
That was different than that. Started as a board game. It probably was. I can't relate. I can't relate. Probably was. But the fact that Will, they call it your Eskimo, Will is the reason he took that risk of having that hard conversation with me in like July of 2004 that put me on a path of deciding
那和那个不一样。开始时是个棋盘游戏。可能吧。我无法感同身受。我无法感同身受。可能吧。但事实是，威尔，他们称之为你的“爱斯基摩人”，威尔是我冒险在2004年7月左右与我进行那次艰难谈话的原因，那让我走上了决定
to change my life. And it is truly Will Arnett. He is the reason and there's nobody else. I'm not the reason. No. I'm the reason that I was like, oh, you know, and it helped that it was the guy that I thought I was emulating. Do you understand what I'm saying?
改变我生活的道路。那真的是威尔·阿内特（Will Arnett）。他是原因，没有别人。我不是原因。不。我是原因，因为我当时想，哦，你知道，而且那个我以为我在效仿的人能这么说，这很有帮助。你明白我在说什么吗？
It's not like somebody else said it like the king told me and that's that that was the thing that was so crazy. I'm like, wait, the king came down to tell you the, what you're doing is not what you really should be doing or what's right or who you even are. I was just going to ask the simple question of how did you learn esteem then? How did you get it back or discover it? Was there a specific moment or was it a gradual? You know, increase of events that led you to go, okay, I can, it's okay to like myself.
并不是别人说了什么，而是国王告诉了我，那才是最疯狂的事情。我心想，等等，国王亲自下来告诉你，你正在做的事情不是你真正应该做的，或者不是正确的，或者甚至不是真正的你。我刚才只是想问一个简单的问题，你是怎么学会自尊的？你是怎么找回它或发现它的？是有某个特定的时刻，还是逐渐发生的？你知道，一系列事件让你觉得，好吧，我可以，喜欢自己是可以的。
It's not a selfish thing to like myself and all of those kinds of things. I mean, I don't know about all of you, but it's a lifelong exploration. I definitely felt like it occurs and has occurred in increments. It started out about my relationships to men. I think I would always idolize male figures and then have them fall off the pedestal because they were, I created something that wasn't even, you know, one couldn't live up to. And in one's art, I think that was sort of the second thing to be okay to be feel comfortable in the things I want to create and having a voice and then just intimacy, the hardest
喜欢自己并不是一件自私的事情，诸如此类。我是说，我不知道你们大家怎么看，但这是一种终身的探索。我绝对觉得它是一点一点发生的，而且已经发生了。它始于我与男性的关系。我想我总是会偶像化男性人物，然后让他们从神坛上跌落，因为他们是……我创造了一些甚至……你知道，一个人无法达到那种高度。而在艺术上，我想那是第二件事，要学会对自己想要创作的东西感到自在，拥有自己的声音，然后就是亲密关系，最难的
intimacy. Yeah. And quite honestly, it hasn't been until about a year and a half ago that I decided like, I'm just at sea and I love so much of my life, but I'm so lost. And it wasn't to, you know, working with a new therapist and quite honestly, like today I can sit in front of you saying, I actually do have self-esteem that's not related to any outside thing. And I didn't have that for 46 years.
亲密关系。是的。老实说，直到大约一年半前，我才决定，我只是在海上漂泊，我非常热爱我的生活，但我太迷茫了。直到，你知道，与一位新的治疗师合作，老实说，就像今天我可以坐在你面前说，我确实拥有了与任何外在事物无关的自尊。而我在46年里都没有过这种感觉。
So it's taken me quite a long time to do that. Can I just say, Bradley, there is such a difference. You know, we got, we had the benefit over the last couple of months, we were in New York and stuff and hanging out for the, the most we've hung out in a number of years. Yeah. I, it has been awesome seeing you in this place and seeing you comfortable. Nothing has made me happier. Just even hanging out at the house with Leah and just seeing you be you and making food.
所以这花了我很长时间才做到。我能说一句吗，布拉德利，真的有很大的不同。你知道，我们，过去几个月我们有幸在纽约等地相处，这是我们多年来相处时间最长的一次。是的。看到你处于这种状态，看到你感到舒适，真是太棒了。没有什么比这更让我开心的了。哪怕只是在家里和莉亚（Lea）一起闲逛，看着你做你自己，做饭。
And I honest to God, dude, I was like, now I'm going to cry. It's made me happy to see you so happy with who you are. And you and I talked last year, I called you, do you remember this and I said, I had a moment last year where I was like, I was so fucked up about like who I was and relationships and all this stuff. And I had this moment. I told Bradley, I woke up and I went to make coffee and I went, holy shit, it's me. It's not everybody else.
我向上帝发誓，伙计，我当时想，现在我要哭了。看到你对自己如此满意，让我感到很高兴。你和我去年谈过，我给你打了电话，你记得吗？我说，我去年有那么一刻，我当时对我是谁、人际关系以及所有这些事情感到非常糟糕。我有过那一刻。我告诉布拉德利，我醒来去煮咖啡，我心想，天哪，是我。不是别人。
It's me. And that moment I talked to Bradley and Bradley was like, yes, he was in the same spot. We talked about it. We talked about this guy and he turned me on to this thing and it was been unbelievable. Anyway, I'm really happy for you, man. Jesus Christ. You guys are awesome. I mean, is can you-
是我。那一刻我告诉了布拉德利，布拉德利说，是的，他当时也处于同样的状态。我们谈论过它。我们谈论了这个家伙，他向我推荐了这个东西，真是不可思议。总之，我真的为你感到高兴，伙计。天哪。你们太棒了。我是说，你能——
I've loved myself since the time I got out of the womb. I got shot out loving the shit out of myself. You're like, I cannot relate to any of this. Nobody can believe that you love yourself. How could you possibly love yourself? Can you guys attribute any of this kind of new found peace and centeredness and all that stuff to- is there a correlation to having your children and trying to provide them some guidance early on that perhaps you may have missed or didn't see come in?
我从出生起就一直爱着自己。我一出生就非常爱自己。你就像是，我无法与这一切产生共鸣。没人能相信你爱自己。你怎么可能爱自己？你们能把这种新发现的平静、专注以及所有这些东西归功于……这与生孩子并试图在早期为他们提供一些你可能错过了或没看到的指导有关联吗？
Is that- I'm sure it's all part of it and it wouldn't be just the only thing. But I know you're both incredible dads, so that's why I ask. I mean, fatherhood is- I mean, everything changed. So the answer is absolutely yes, along with like, you know, how I drink water. I mean, it's like, you know, every single thing is absolutely shaded by or brought out in glorious colors by the fact that I get to be a father to a wonderful human being. I mean, it's just the absolute greatest thing. And I think it really- in regards to the work we do, I was literally talking about this
是那样吗——我相信这都是其中的一部分，而且这不会是唯一的原因。但我知道你们俩都是了不起的父亲，所以我才这么问。我是说，为人父是——我是说，一切都变了。所以答案绝对是肯定的，就像，你知道，我喝水的方式一样。我是说，就像，你知道，每一件事都被我能成为一个了不起的人类的父亲这一事实所渲染或展现出绚丽的色彩。我是说，这绝对是最棒的事情。而且我认为它真的——关于我们所做的工作，我前几天还在谈论这个，
a couple of days ago and thinking about, you know, you have this wonderful thing or a breakthrough with the script, right? Or you're like, oh my gosh, this person and you have a wonderful moment on a set or wonderful moment in the editing room, you have like 40 of those moments every day with your kid. That are that level of joy. Exactly. So it's like, the idea- I mean, and that's just- that's not spinning it, that is just the truth.
思考着，你知道，你有一个很棒的事情或者剧本上的突破，对吧？或者你觉得，哦天哪，这个人，你在片场有一个美妙的时刻，或者在剪辑室有一个美妙的时刻，你每天和你的孩子有40个这样的时刻。那种程度的快乐。完全正确。所以就像，这个想法——我是说，那不是在美化，那只是事实。
Yeah. You know? I was like, Lee looked at me the other day and it was like, this is kind of crude sometimes. She's like, you know, after she goes to the toilet, she sits there waiting for me to wipe her butt. And it's like, I'm watching this kid and she's like, okay, daddy. And I'm just like, this is the greatest moment of my life right now. This is the fucking- this is the best moment of my life right now.
是的。你知道吗？我当时想，莉亚前几天看着我，就像是，这有时有点粗鲁。她说，你知道，在她上完厕所后，她坐在那里等我给她擦屁股。我看着这个孩子，她就像是，好的，爸爸。我当时就想，这是我生命中最伟大的时刻。这是该死的——这是我生命中最美好的时刻。
I mean, it's just crazy. Scotty and I were walking down the street in Chicago and we saw this one woman carrying like maybe a five-year-old kid in her hands. So he's kind of a big kid and her- and his shoe fell off and she was pissed. She was walking like 50 miles an hour. And then 20 steps behind was the husband with two other kids in there. Everybody's screaming and crying. And I turned to Scotty and I go, we both looked at each other, we're like, thank God.
我是说，这太疯狂了。斯科蒂和我在芝加哥街头走着，我们看到一个女人手里抱着一个大概五岁的孩子。他是个大孩子，她的——他的鞋子掉了，她很生气。她走得像每小时50英里一样快。然后后面20步是丈夫，带着另外两个孩子。每个人都在尖叫和哭泣。我转向斯科蒂说，我们俩看着对方，我们心想，谢天谢地。
Fuck that. Weed. I have to say that is not my experience, you know? Not only is that not my experience, the other thing that's not- people keep saying it flies by and I'm like, I guess so. I have not experienced that. I feel like I have changed 20,000 diapers. It's like Groundhog Day.
去他的。杂草。我必须说那不是我的经历，你知道吗？不仅那不是我的经历，另一件事也不是——人们一直说时间过得飞快，我心想，大概吧。我没有那种感觉。我觉得我已经换了20,000个尿布了。就像《土拨鼠之日》（Groundhog Day）。
It's like things couldn't progress more, you know, faster. That's hysterical. Yeah. There's fast parts and slow parts, but the reason I asked that question earlier is I did find for me that one of the things it does too is it accelerates your work on yourself because you want to not infect them with the crap you don't have yet figured out. Yes. 100%.
就像事情不可能进展得更快了，你知道。这太搞笑了。是的。有快的部分，也有慢的部分，但我刚才问那个问题的原因是，我确实发现对我来说，它所做的一件事是加速了你对自己的工作，因为你不想用你还没弄明白的烂摊子去感染他们。是的。100%。
Yeah. Yeah. Of course. There's that saying that this guy knows. He says like, I don't want my kids to have to recover from their childhood. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Recover from your childhood.
是的。是的。当然。有句谚语这个家伙知道。他说，我不希望我的孩子必须从他们的童年中恢复过来。是的。哦，我喜欢那个。从你的童年中恢复过来。
Yeah. Or from mine, but certainly from theirs and, you know- Sorry to interrupt. Just real quick on that self-esteem thing. I do think a key element that I've discovered is I found myself saying, telling me and myself and others a narrative about certain things, my childhood, my relationship to my parents, like this thing, press play. I'm a kid from Philly.
是的。或者从我的童年中，但肯定是从他们的童年中，而且，你知道——抱歉打断一下。关于自尊那件事，很快说一下。我确实认为我发现的一个关键要素是，我发现自己一直在对自己和他人讲述关于某些事情的叙事，我的童年，我与父母的关系，就像这件事，按下播放键。我是个来自费城的孩子。
I got a chip in my shoulder. It's like, I'm always going to look up. It's whatever it is. And eventually you're like, actually, what is the truth? Right. Like, what was my childhood? And the minute I actually had a real assessment of my childhood, my upbringing, then I had a foundation to work off of, without the foundation, it is, I think, impossible, literally impossible
我肩上有个筹码。就像，我总是会仰望。不管是什么。最终你会想，实际上，真相是什么？对吧。比如，我的童年是什么样的？当我真正对我的童年、我的成长经历进行真实评估的那一刻，我就有了可以努力的基础，没有这个基础，我认为，简直是不可能的
to build self-esteem because you're building on something that's fabricated. Because you chose not to acknowledge your childhood? You didn't remember it? Or why? No, I remembered it. It was shaped by whatever insecurity or however I learned how to survive, I thought, in this world, I created a narrative that allowed me to survive in the way that I could. But the older you get, the more narrow that your life becomes because you're not really
建立自尊，因为你建立在虚构的东西之上。因为你选择不承认你的童年？你不记得了吗？还是为什么？不，我记得。它是由任何不安全感或我学会如何在这个世界上生存的方式塑造的，我想，我创造了一个让我能以那种方式生存的叙事。但你越老，你的生活就越狭窄，因为你并没有真正
living your true life because it's not even based on reality. And it's really popular to keep telling a story. Whatever story you're telling about yourself is a way that your life is going to go. What you've got to do is start to change the story. It's like, there's this idea that anytime you take a memory out and look at it, you change it every time and you put it back and you change it. So whatever you have happening now, Sean, it kind of goes to what you're saying. If you're not feeling good about yourself and then you take that memory out, you affect
过着你真实的生活，因为它甚至不是基于现实的。而且一直讲一个故事非常流行。无论你对自己讲什么故事，都是你生活将要走的方向。你必须做的是开始改变这个故事。就像，有一个想法是，每当你拿出一个记忆并审视它时，你每次都会改变它，然后你把它放回去，你就改变了它。所以无论你现在发生了什么，肖恩，这有点符合你所说的。如果你对自己感觉不好，然后你拿出那个记忆，你就影响了
it. And you go, well, this is what happened. Well, that's actually kind of what you're saying, Billy. That's not what happened. And what you're doing is you've been telling yourself this fucked up story and it starts to get worse. So the gap between what happened and what actually happened and what is, that gap gets wider and wider and there's more and more pain in there when you do that.
它。然后你说，好吧，这就是发生的事情。嗯，这实际上有点像你所说的，比利。那不是发生的事情。你所做的是你一直在对自己讲这个该死的故事，它开始变得更糟。所以发生的事情与实际发生的事情以及现状之间的差距，那个差距变得越来越大，当你这样做时，里面有越来越多的痛苦。
Stolen election. Mm. Anyway. You won't stop. Sean, Jesus, we're not going to check the fucking voting machines again. Sean, real quick, January 6th, where were you? Real quick. We'll be right back.
被窃取的选举。嗯。总之。你不会停下来的。肖恩，天哪，我们不会再去检查那些该死的投票机了。肖恩，快点，1月6日，你在哪？快点。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. Well I wanted to ask a question about an hour ago about your career, but I've never asked you. I can't believe I never asked you. I'm sure you got this in the press junket and everything, but I don't know the answer. Why did you pick a star is born to Jason's point way, way earlier when it was done, I don't know, two, three times before and weren't you scared to take on such a massive iconic kind of thing?
现在回到节目。嗯，我想在一个小时前问一个关于你职业生涯的问题，但我从来没问过你。我不敢相信我从来没问过你。我相信你在新闻发布会和所有这些场合都遇到过这个问题，但我不知道答案。为什么你选择了《一个明星的诞生》（A Star Is Born），按照杰森很久很久以前的观点，当它之前已经被拍过两三次的时候，你不怕承担这种巨大的、标志性的东西吗？
It's hard to ask such a dumb question. Because it does put a target on, I mean, it takes a lot of guts, dude. Yeah, and I know you've been asked that, I'm sure, a million times, but I've never asked you that. Well, I mean, as Jason knows, you can't really choose what it is is going to motivate you to do all that work that it fucking takes to write and direct something. And it's just sort of, you know, I always deep down thought maybe I could like play a rock star only because I thought I could crush air guitar, you know, as Will knows.
问这么蠢的问题很难。因为它确实把目标放在了……我是说，这需要很大的胆量，伙计。是的，我知道你肯定被问过一百万次了，但我从来没问过你。嗯，我是说，正如杰森所知，你无法真正选择是什么激励你去完成所有那些该死的工作来编写和导演某样东西。这只是，你知道，我内心深处一直认为也许我可以扮演一个摇滚明星，只是因为我觉得我可以碾压空气吉他，你知道，正如威尔所知。
So much so, but I'm so crazy about like making sure that I went on Jimmy Fallon and I asked, I said, can I do an air guitar just to see if I believed it? Right. I'm not kidding. So I went on, I went on the tonight show and I said, can I do down by the river by Neil Young? And I did it and I looked at it and I was like, I think I buy that. Okay.
以至于，但我非常疯狂地确保我上了吉米·法伦（Jimmy Fallon）的节目，我问，我说，我可以表演一段空气吉他来看看我是否相信它吗？对吧。我没开玩笑。所以我上了，我上了《今夜秀》（Tonight Show），我说，我可以表演尼尔·杨（Neil Young）的《Down by the River》吗？我表演了，我看了看，我心想，我想我买账了。好吧。
I'll do a star is born. That's hysterical. That's fucking hysterical. I'm like, I think I could pull this off. I wasn't sure before, but I think maybe I'm going to use the tonight show. It was a workshop. Have you seen our net do air base? Oh God.
我会拍《一个明星的诞生》。这太搞笑了。这太该死地搞笑了。我心想，我想我可以做到这一点。我之前不确定，但我认为也许我要利用《今夜秀》。那是一个研讨会。你看过阿内特表演空气贝斯吗？哦，天哪。
Yeah. Are you kidding? Night court. Come on. And then he goes right into law and order. Law and order. Law and order. I was, no, but you did night court too.
是的。你在开玩笑吗？《夜间法庭》（Night Court）。得了吧。然后他直接进入《法律与秩序》（Law and Order）。《法律与秩序》。《法律与秩序》。我当时，不，但你也拍了《夜间法庭》。
Didn't you? I've done, I've done night court. You know, the best one of the best air guitarists of all time is John Glazer. But we, I went, yeah, we did air guitar with Conan and I threw him the flute in the Law and Order team song and then Conan started doing the fucking, no, the clarinet. The air clarinet. So you had to wet the reed, wet the reed, wet the reed. So now I have another thing.
不是吗？我拍过，我拍过《夜间法庭》。你知道，有史以来最好的空气吉他手之一是约翰·格雷泽（John Glazer）。但我们，我去了，是的，我们和柯南（Conan）一起表演了空气吉他，我扔给他《法律与秩序》主题曲里的长笛，然后柯南开始做那个该死的，不，单簧管。空气单簧管。所以你必须润湿簧片，润湿簧片，润湿簧片。所以现在我有另一件事了。
So a star is born and then Leonard Bernstein, what is the music thing? What, when did the music love stars? So the truth is, the stars born, I wanted, I wanted to tell a love story. I always thought like that seemed moving to me. That's what I, and then I thought, well, there's no better way as you know, Sean, is like, you can't hide when you sing. I mean, you literally cannot hide. It's impossible because your voice is the instrument and it has to be loose for the
所以《一个明星的诞生》，然后是伦纳德·伯恩斯坦（Leonard Bernstein），音乐是什么？什么，你什么时候开始热爱音乐的？所以事实是，《一个明星的诞生》，我想，我想讲一个爱情故事。我一直认为那对我来说很感人。这就是我，然后我想，好吧，没有比这更好的方式了，正如你所知，肖恩，当你唱歌时你无法隐藏。我是说，你真的无法隐藏。这不可能，因为你的声音是乐器，它必须放松，这样
chords to vibrate. And if you're tense or you're stuck, it's not going to work. So I thought, gosh, if I could like marry that in a way, that would be, that would be awesome. And so that's how that sort of started and got it. That was a property that was around Warner Brothers and Clint East was going to do it and he asked me, but I didn't think I could play Jackson Maine. I hadn't done American Sniper yet.
和弦才能振动。如果你紧张或卡住了，它就不会奏效。所以我心想，天哪，如果我能以某种方式结合这一点，那会是，那会很棒。所以这就是它开始的方式，明白了。那是华纳兄弟公司周围的一个项目，克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint East）打算拍它，他问我，但我认为我演不了杰克逊·梅恩（Jackson Maine）。我还没拍《美国狙击手》（American Sniper）。
I hadn't done Elephant Man and I thought, I honestly thought that I couldn't, I would be acting. Like I was like, I just don't know enough honestly about life and shit. I don't think I could play this guy. And then once I thought I could play it, he didn't want to do it. And then I thought, well, you know what, I am 40. All the directors I admire, they don't really want me to do their movies. So what am I going to do?
我还没拍《象人》（Elephant Man），我心想，我老实说认为我不能，我那是在演戏。就像我当时想，我老实说对生活和那些烂事了解得不够多。我不认为我能演这个家伙。然后一旦我认为我可以演它，他就不想拍了。然后我想，好吧，你知道吗，我40岁了。我钦佩的所有导演，他们并不真的想让我拍他们的电影。那我该怎么办？
And I, and I, all I want to do is be at the center of the creative experience. I'm going to have to fucking do it myself. I've spent a decade. Wait a second. When you say that, no, the directors you admire want you to do their movies. I mean, it's just the truth. Look, I had, in no way, look, I've had an incredible opportunity to work with great directors. But, you know, like the Cohen brothers, Martin Scorsese, Paul Thomas Sanders, David Fincher,
而且我，而且我，我只想成为创意体验的中心。我得该死地自己做。我花了一十年。等一下。当你这么说时，不，你钦佩的导演想让你拍他们的电影。我是说，这只是事实。看，我没有，看，我有绝佳的机会与伟大的导演合作。但是，你知道，像科恩兄弟（Cohen brothers）、马丁·斯科塞斯（Martin Scorsese）、保罗·托马斯·安德森（Paul Thomas Anderson）、大卫·芬奇（David Fincher），
you know, the list goes on and on. We, I just couldn't, you know, be in any of those guys movies. Catherine Bigelow. So, so, and I was 40 and I was like, I just spent a decade on the road, basically, and had like, you know, two or three experiences where, you know, it took, it took like a pound of flesh out of me because I am so invested in the projects I do. And I felt like I wasn't working with people that I really wanted to work with to grow and get better.
你知道，名单还在继续。我们，我只是不能，你知道，出现在那些家伙的电影里。凯瑟琳·毕格罗（Catherine Bigelow）。所以，所以，我40岁了，我心想，我刚在路上花了一十年，基本上，有两三次经历，你知道，它从我身上剥掉了一层皮，因为我对我做的项目投入太多了。我觉得我没有和那些我真正想合作的人一起工作来成长和变得更好。
And it was like, I'm 40, I want a kid, I want to slow down, and I want to do stuff that I really care about. And that's what started that. So, so, so now that you're doing Leonard Bernstein. And that was another thing. I always wanted to be a conductor, honestly. Like, since I was a kid, Bugs Bunny, Tom and Jerry, you know, and then spending hundreds of hours by myself as a kid pretending I could conduct like air guitar.
就像是，我40岁了，我想要个孩子，我想慢下来，我想做我真正关心的事情。这就是开始这一切的原因。所以，所以，所以现在你在拍伦纳德·伯恩斯坦。那是另一回事。我一直想成为一名指挥家，老实说。就像，从我还是个孩子的时候起，兔八哥（Bugs Bunny）、汤姆和杰瑞（Tom and Jerry），你知道，然后作为孩子独自花了几百个小时假装我可以像空气吉他那样指挥。
And then this project was around. I just finished a Star Wars board and I thought, gosh, let me research Leonard Bernstein. If I feel like there's a story in there that I could commit four and a half years to because I don't know how to do it any without any with a shorter time. Can I write it and do it? And then that's how that started. And I, and I just did all this research about this incredible family, the Bernstein's and Felicia Montalegre, his wife, fascinating, their relationship, fascinating the kids.
然后这个项目就在附近。我刚拍完《一个明星的诞生》，我心想，天哪，让我研究一下伦纳德·伯恩斯坦。如果我觉得里面有一个故事，我可以投入四年半的时间，因为我不知道怎么在更短的时间内完成它。我可以写它并拍它吗？然后这就是它开始的方式。而且我，而且我只是做了所有关于这个了不起的家庭的研究，伯恩斯坦一家和费利西亚·蒙塔莱格雷（Felicia Montalegre），他的妻子，迷人，他们的关系，迷人，孩子们。
And I thought, and how they're articulate, they are about about their feelings. There's the movie, a movie about marriage, a movie about family. That's it. It's nuclear because it's this fucking music that is just, you know, music is nuclear. I had a secret weapon in a Star Wars board and it was Lady Gaga. The secret weapon I have in this movie is fucking Leonard Bernstein and Gustav Mahler. That music. And, and, but, but what is the, what is your connection with music?
我心想，而且他们对自己的感受是多么清晰。这是一部电影，一部关于婚姻的电影，一部关于家庭的电影。就是这样。它是核能的，因为这是该死的音乐，你知道，音乐是核能的。我在《一个明星的诞生》里有一个秘密武器，那就是Lady Gaga。我在这一部电影里的秘密武器是该死的伦纳德·伯恩斯坦和古斯塔夫·马勒（Gustav Mahler）。那音乐。而且，而且，但是，但是你与音乐的联系是什么？
Like, did you? I don't remember you singing Bradley before Star Wars. I never sang. No, no. Yeah. So when you were like singing the thing, I'm like, wait, Bradley's singing all these songs. But I will.
比如，你？我不记得你在《一个明星的诞生》之前唱过歌，布拉德利。我从来没唱过。不，不。是的。所以当你唱歌的时候，我心想，等等，布拉德利在唱所有这些歌。但我会。
I worked my ass off. I know. Obviously. I mean. You know, I had to work really hard because we did everything live. We sang everything live. Dude, it was, it's incredible that you did it. It's fucking nuts.
我拼命工作。我知道。显然。我是说。你知道，我必须非常努力地工作，因为我们现场做了所有事情。我们现场唱了所有东西。伙计，你做到了真是不可思议。这太该死地疯狂了。
It's, it's fucking crazy. Yeah. Look at Jason. Jason couldn't do anything. No, no. If you ask them right now. I can't even do my hair. Jason, do something.
这，这太该死地疯狂了。是的。看看杰森。杰森什么都做不了。不，不。如果你现在问他们。我连头发都弄不好。杰森，做点什么。
He's a gorgeous man in the world. Look at him. He's so gorgeous. Look at him snap. Both hands. Both hands. Same time. And talk, and talk.
他是世界上最华丽的男人。看看他。他太华丽了。看他打响指。双手。双手。同时。而且说话，而且说话。
What about, where does the, you know, this is kind of a trite question. I'm sure you've answered this one a bunch of times too, but the passion between acting and directing, they're completely different in their creative agendas, endeavors and goals. One is a bit more singular and, and the other one is a bit more sort of global with multiple departments and you're, you're anyway, where do those two things balance for you and sit, you know, I'm not going to say which do you like more, but what, what, what type of mood are you in when you gravitate more towards one versus the other? The truth is it's always been the same thing.
那，你知道，这是一个陈词滥调的问题。我相信你也回答过很多次了，但表演和导演之间的激情，它们在创意议程、努力和目标上完全不同。一个是更单一的，而另一个是更全球化的，有多个部门，而且你，你总之，那两件事对你来说在哪里平衡和坐落，你知道，我不会说你更喜欢哪一个，但当你更倾向于其中一个而不是另一个时，你处于什么样的情绪中？事实是，它一直都是同一件事。
It's never been different. Whether it was being on alias and asking for everybody's dailies on VHS tapes that I would watch at home and sit in the editing room every time I wasn't on set. Cause I really, all I did was like do three scenes and ask Sidney Bristol like how her trip was and like make popcorn. So I didn't, it wasn't doing anything. And, and, but I learned like this was fascinated about the process of making cinema and, and it's always been that.
它从来没有不同过。无论是在《双面女间谍》片场，要求每个人的每日样片（dailies）放在VHS磁带上，我会在家里看，每次我不在片场时就坐在剪辑室里。因为我真的，我所做的只是拍三场戏，问西德尼·布里斯托（Sidney Bristol）她的旅行怎么样，然后爆爆米花。所以我没有，我什么都没做。而且，而且，但我学到了，就像这让我对制作电影的过程着迷，而且一直都是这样。
And so it's never really changed. And I don't even see it as two separate things, Jason, it's, it's all part of the same thing. But the answer is there's nothing I enjoy more artistically than, than doing the things that, that you and I've talked about a lot, which is, you know, having an idea, exploring it, writing it, um, and then asking a group of people that you admire and inspire you to come help you do it and create it and then put it out in the world. It's greatest, it's the greatest gift ever. It's great.
所以它从来没有真正改变过。我甚至不把它看作两件分开的事情，杰森，它，它都是同一件事的一部分。但答案是，在艺术上，没有什么比做那些你和我谈论过很多的事情更让我享受的了，那就是，你知道，有一个想法，探索它，写它，嗯，然后邀请一群你钦佩并激励你的人来帮你做它，创造它，然后把它推向世界。这是最伟大的，这是有史以来最伟大的礼物。这很棒。
If there's nothing better, there's just nothing better. Yeah. I love that. That's our first commercial break. Well now a word from our sponsors. Yeah. I was just going to say, let's go from that to, I think you told us. Bradley, I was just thinking, he's talking about the 10 years of being on the road.
没有什么比这更好的了，真的没有什么比这更好的了。是的。我喜欢那个。那是我们的第一个商业广告时间。好吧，现在听听我们赞助商的话。是的。我正想说，让我们从那个转到，我想你告诉过我们。布拉德利，我刚才在想，他在谈论在路上那10年。
And I was thinking about, uh, the hangover movies. I mean, you, you went and you did like, we're not even mentioning the fact that you were in three of the, the, the top grossing. Can I show you this real quick? Can I show you guys this real quick? So I haven't talked to NZZAC together in years and my daughter woke up this morning if I play this kind of play. So this is my daughter this morning.
我在想，《宿醉》电影。我是说，你，你去了，你拍了，我们甚至没提到你参与了三部票房最高的电影的事实。我能很快给你们看这个吗？我能很快给你们看这个吗？所以我已经好几年没和NZZAC一起谈过了，我女儿今天早上醒来，如果我放这个……所以这是我女儿今天早上。
So I texted those guys and I was like, hangover for, let's do it. Because remember who let the dogs out? That's like the thing of us walking down the hall. Dude, that's amazing. Did you get that from watching the movie or what? How did she know? Yeah, I show it to her. We watch it every Friday.
所以我给那些家伙发了短信，我说，宿醉4，我们拍吧。因为记得《Who Let the Dogs Out》吗？那就像我们走在走廊里的事情。伙计，那太棒了。你是从看电影里得到的还是什么？她怎么知道的？是的，我给她看。我们每个星期五都看。
Yeah. She's four years old. Yeah. Way to go, Shanya. She's watching, she's watching a hangover already. You know what? I'm glad you didn't have kids. I'm glad you didn't have kids.
是的。她四岁。是的。干得好，香雅（Shanya）。她已经在看《宿醉》了。你知道吗？我很高兴你没孩子。我很高兴你没孩子。
And now I get why your father left too. Listen. Oh Jesus. We're going to get real. Humor. Here's the thing about mean humor. Humor is a thing. Somebody at, somebody at Franny's school, I guess said to her that they liked horrible
现在我明白你父亲为什么也离开了。听着。哦，天哪。我们要来真的了。幽默。关于刻薄的幽默就是这样。幽默是一回事。弗兰妮（Franny）学校里的某个人，我想对她说他们喜欢《恶老板》（Horrible Bosses）之类的。所以她说你想看它。所以我那天晚上开始和弗兰妮一起看，还有我10岁的孩子。所以弗兰妮15岁，梅普尔（Maple）10岁。我们看了电影5秒钟，而且，安妮斯顿（Aniston）在谈论弄断她的手指，对着佩恩·贝格利（Penn Badgley）自慰，看着史蒂夫·W（Steve W）。她就像，哇，哇，我完全忘了它有多不合适了。就像，你必须小心。
bosses or something. So she says you wanted to watch it. So I started watching with, with Franny the other night and my 10 year old. So Franny's 15, Maple's 10. And we're five seconds into the movie and, and Aniston is talking about breaking her finger, fingering herself to Penn Badgley, watching Steve W. She's like, whoa, whoa, I totally forgot how inappropriate it was. And it's just like, you got to be careful.
你必须小心。我知道。我不太擅长那个。我必须说。如果你问我女儿像《白莲花度假村》（White Lotus），她会说，那个在手提箱里拉屎的家伙。但她还没看《宿醉》，对吧？布拉德利，当你膝盖，膝盖深陷在一部电影里时，像这样，你正在做的。
You got to be careful. I know. I'm not very good at that. I have to say. If you ask my daughter like a white lotus, she'll go, the guy who pooped in the suitcase. But she is not yet watching Hangover, right? Bradley, when you're knees, knees deep in a, in a, in a movie like this, that you're working on.
哦，好。在电影里。不，只是，那可能朝任何方向发展。你，你有任何其他你可以考虑的项目或任何你正在考虑超越那个的东西吗？你是24小时全神贯注于这一件事吗？我无法想象你能专注于它。我认为每种经历都是不同的，但我会说这个。
Oh, good. In a movie. No, it just, that could have gone either any, any direction. Do you, are you, do you have any kind of other project that you can think about or any kind of thing that you're thinking beyond that? Are you all in 24 hours a day on this one thing? And I can't imagine you can focus on it. I think every experience is different, but I will say this.
上个月，我一直没睡。我真的没能睡着。我一直在脑子里放这部电影，而且，我有胃酸倒流，我从来没得过。我有，你知道，床边的胃药。现在莱尼（Lenny），莱尼是个失眠症患者。电影里实际上有一个场景，朱莉娅·维加（Julia Vega），她一直和他们在一起，就像擦掉他脸上的拇指。
The last month, I have not been sleeping. I really have not been able to sleep. I keep playing the movie in my head and, and I have like acid reflex, which I've never had. I've like, you know, pepsidacy by the bedside. Now Lenny, Lenny couldn't, Lenny was an insomniac. And there's actually a scene in the movie where, where, where Julia Vega, who was there with them for the whole life, like wipes the thumbs off his face.
我不知道发生了什么。但我必须说，这一部让我相当着迷。哦，哇。你有时间在周末或深夜做些愚蠢的事情吗？那是，而且为人父字面上就是那样。是的。是的。莉亚的母亲很了不起。
I don't know what's happening. But this one, I have to say, has me pretty possessed. Oh, wow. Do you have time to do anything stupid on the weekends or late at night? Is that, and then being a dad is literally that. Yeah. Yeah. And Leah's mother is incredible.
而且，但我们共同监护。但当我拥有她时，你知道，只有我和莉亚，而且，谢天谢地，关于清醒和谦逊的另一件事是，我意识到我不能在没有帮助的情况下拍这部电影并照顾她。所以字面上今天晚上在几分钟内，有人要来，他会留在纽约，帮忙，帮忙到拍摄结束，我以前从来不会这样做。但我谢天谢地我正在这样做。我知道，这太棒了。
And, but we share custody. But when I have her, you know, it's just me and Leah and, and thank God, here's another thing about being sober and having humility is like, I realized I can't do this movie and take care of it without any help. So literally tonight in like minutes away, someone is coming that's going to stay in New York and help, help out till the end of the shoot, which I never would have done. But I'm thank goodness I'm doing it. I know, which is amazing.
你从来没做过。你在那方面是个了不起的父亲。杰森之前说过，但我们都，我们都见证了它，而且你参与其中。但只是自私地因为那些关于40个时刻的事情，就像生活，你知道，生活时刻。我只是喜欢它。我只是，我不想要任何我可以和她在一起或不和她在一起的时刻。是的。
You've never done. You're an incredible dad in that way. Jason said it before, but we all, we've all gotten to witness it and you're in. But only selfishly because of those things about the 40 moments of like life, you know, life moment. I just love it. I just, I don't want any moment that I could be with or not to be with her. Yeah.
是的。当然。这就是为什么我喜欢后来她会说，爸爸，你从来没有分开过。你太，你，你一直粘着我。不，但我认为那是一件好事。我知道。这就是为什么我是个糟糕的父亲。那种联系。
Yeah. For sure. That's why I like later she'd be like, dad, and you never were apart. You were so, you, you stuck to me all the time. No, but I thought it was a good thing. I know. It's why I'm fucked up dad. That connection.
不，那种联系。很多爱。杰森，你孩子的名字是快。三，二，一。是的。珍妮（Genny）。这就是我在说的。不，你们俩都是伟大的父亲，而且，而且是的，你是对的。
No, that connection. Much love. Jason, your kid's name is quick. Three, two, one. Yeah. Genny. This is what I'm talking about. No, you guys are both great dads and, and yeah, you're right.
你不想，甚至不是你不想让你的孩子以后那样说，你只是不想现在不做。你不想错过它。而且你想。我只是享受它。它真的太。我只是喜欢和她在一起。我只是喜欢它。
You don't want to, and it's not even that you don't want your kids to say that later is you just don't want to not do it now. You don't want to miss it. And you want to. I just enjoy it. It's really so. I just enjoy hanging with her. I just love it.
是的。是的。你想拍你身后的象人吗？是的。他在那儿。是的。你，你在那部戏里是我一生中看过的最好的表演之一。哦，伙计。
Yeah. Yeah. Do you want to picture the elephant man behind you? Yeah. There he is. Yes. You, you in that play was one of the best performances I've ever seen in my whole life. Oh man.
是的。谢谢。在布斯剧院（Booth Theater），对吧？是的。我们起源的地方。是的。太疯狂了。我真恶心我没看到那个。
Yeah. Thank you. At the Booth Theater, right? Yes. We're originated. Yeah. So crazy. I'm so sick that I didn't see that.
它太好了。是的。而且你知道我注意到了什么吗？布拉德利，每天晚上，如果我错了请纠正我，但我注意到的是你错了。哦，你是说关于这个故事？好吧。你作为象人的表演在你的手上，你的手上有一根橡皮筋
It was so good. Yeah. And you know what I noticed? Bradley, every single night, correct me if I'm wrong, but what I noticed is you're wrong. Oh, you mean about this story? Okay. You had as, as your performance as the elephant man on your hand, you had a rubber band around
绕着你的手，对吧？不，不，不。我做了我小时候常做的那件事，你知道，我相信你们也做过，你知道，这件事。哦，你做了那个？你就一直把它放在那里？把手指折叠在彼此上面。是的。
your hand, right? No, no, no. I did this thing that I used to do as a kid, you know, that I'm sure you guys did, you know, this thing. Oh, you did that? And you just held it there the whole time? Fold the fingers over each other. Yeah.
所以我以为你的手上有一根橡皮筋？不。但你没有吗？我不认为，我不记得你告诉我你的背部全搞砸了。哦，是的，伙计。不仅如此，我脸的左侧比右侧大，我的右手，因为我们做了365场表演，我的右手实际上开始像有问题了。是的。
So I thought you had a rubber band around your hand? No. But didn't you? I don't think, I don't remember you telling me that your back was all fucked up. Oh yeah, man. Not only that, the left side of my face got larger than the right and my right hand, because we did 365 performances and my right hand actually started to like have issues. Yeah.
所以当，你从那以后演过戏吗？不幸的是，我没有。而且我，是的，这很糟糕，因为我做，它是，它是那些事情之一，它是最难的事情，它是最有回报的，它是最单调的事情。就像它是所有这些事情，对吧？而且也很耗时，对吧？是的。但它的单调，你就像，哦，天哪。
So when, have you done theater since then? I have not, unfortunately. And I, yeah, which sucks, because I do, it's, it's one of those things where it's the hardest thing, it's the most rewarding and it's the most monotonous thing. It's like it's all these things, right? And time consuming, too, right? Yeah. But the monotony of it, and you're like, oh my God.
然后你就像，哦，它有点棒。哦，天哪。哦，我有点喜欢它。我，我希望在《大师》（Maestro）之后马上做，实际上。也许威廉斯敦（Williamstown），因为那样它是一个五周的事情，砰，你进进出出。噢。是的，那会很好。我记得看到那个。
And then you're like, oh, it's kind of great. Oh, Jesus. Oh, I kind of love it. I'm, I hope to do it right after Maestro, actually. Maybe Williamstown, because then it's a five week thing, bam, you're in and out. Ooh. Yeah, that'd be good. I remember seeing that.
然后你会觉得，哦，这还挺棒的。天哪。哦，我有点喜欢它了。其实我希望在《音乐大师》之后马上做这件事。也许是威廉斯敦，因为那样的话只需要五周，砰，进出很快。哦。是的，那会很不错。我记得看过那个。
I mean, it's the greatest thing in the world. Dude, what was the one you did before that, three days ago? I mean, even, what did you think of the tour? I mean, the energy of the tour, though, right? When you guys were there. I mean, I love it. I was sick. There's nothing like it.
我的意思是，这是世界上最棒的事情。伙计，你三天前做的那个是什么来着？我的意思是，甚至，你觉得巡演怎么样？我的意思是，巡演的活力，对吧？当你们在那里的时候。我的意思是，我喜欢它。我当时病了。没有什么比这更好的了。
There's just fucking, there's nothing like it. I was sick. How funny though, Will, you're like, I got this crazy idea. We're all talking about it, about doing this thing. Man, I think it sounds great. Well, cut to. Oh my God. This is the 100th episode.
真的他妈的，没有什么比这更好的了。我当时病了。不过威尔，真有意思，你说，我有个疯狂的想法。我们都在谈论它，关于做这件事。伙计，我觉得听起来很棒。好吧，切到。天哪。这是第100集。
What? Yeah. What the fuck? It's really ridiculous. It's crazy thing we're going to do it this time, either way, we couldn't have had the more perfect 100th guest. Oh, man. Really? It's perfection.
什么？是啊。搞什么鬼？这真的很荒谬。我们这次要这样做真是太疯狂了，无论如何，我们不可能有比这更完美的第100位嘉宾了。天哪。真的吗？这是完美。
It makes sense because we're all family. About 50 times I've forgotten that we're doing the podcast right now. Me too. I fucking totally forgot. I know. You know? It's so nice. Yeah, Bradley, man, I'm so glad that you're on this 100th episode with us.
这很有道理，因为我们都是一家人。我已经有大约50次忘记我们现在正在录播客了。我也是。我他妈完全忘了。我知道。你知道吗？这太好了。是啊，布莱德利，伙计，我真高兴你能和我们一起参加这第100集。
You're such a big part of all of our lives. I love you, man. And just keep fucking doing it. Keep reaching. I don't think I'd ever say this earnestly to anybody, but keep fucking reaching for, you know, the stars and hitting for outside of the park and taking big swings. It's fucking awesome and inspiring and just love you, dude. Love you, Bradley.
你是我们所有人生活中很重要的一部分。我爱你，伙计。继续他妈的做下去。继续努力。我想我永远不会对任何人如此真诚地说这句话，但继续他妈的去追求，你知道，去摘星星，去打出全垒打，去大胆尝试。这太他妈棒了，太鼓舞人心了，我就是爱你，伙计。爱你，布莱德利。
I love you guys. Really? It really is. It's very exciting to watch you go. Oh, man. Thank you. And we wish you were here tonight. I know.
我也爱你们。真的吗？确实如此。看着你们前进真是太令人兴奋了。天哪。谢谢。我们真希望你今晚能在这里。我知道。
I was listening and I thought, oh, fuck, I wish I was there, man. When does the movie come out ish? Jason will give a toast in your name. Please. Yeah. It won't come out till the fall of 23. I think. Okay.
我当时在听，我想，哦，该死，我真希望我在那里，伙计。电影大概什么时候上映？杰森会以你的名义敬酒。拜托。是啊。我想直到23年秋天才会上映。好吧。
Holy shit. You're shooting the whole thing out in New York? No. No. We started in Massachusetts. Then we're in New York, East Hampton. And then we take a break and then we go to Italy for three weeks and then we end in London. And the last day, the last two days are Mahler's Resurrection at Ely Cathedral.
天哪。你们是在纽约拍摄整部电影吗？不。不。我们是在马萨诸塞州开始的。然后我们在纽约，东汉普顿。然后我们休息一下，然后去意大利待三周，最后在伦敦结束。最后一天，最后两天是马勒的《复活》在伊利大教堂的演出。
If you know that, like it's one of the largest Gothic cathedrals in the world, live conducting it with 180-core, 74 orchestra, the soprano, mezzo-soprano, we just cast these incredible singers. I mean, it's going to be, I can't even like... Bradley, I'm so friggin excited. Jesus. Who knows if it'll work? You know, because we're going to do it live. Like it's like it either works or doesn't.
如果你知道的话，它是世界上最大的哥特式大教堂之一，现场指挥180人的合唱团，74人的管弦乐队，女高音，女中音，我们刚刚选定了这些不可思议的歌手。我的意思是，这将是，我甚至不能……布莱德利，我太他妈兴奋了。天哪。谁知道它会不会成功？你知道，因为我们要现场直播。就像它要么成功，要么失败。
Just taking on the scope and the scale and just the logistics of it alone, you know? It sounds impressive. I just couldn't admire you more. No, it's amazing. And just to have that kind of, that ambition, speaking of it, Jason did, you know, he's going to tee off tomorrow and he's going to play 18 and then he's going to do a six-mile run on a treadmill. I mean, that's ambition too.
光是承担它的范围、规模和后勤工作，你知道吗？听起来令人印象深刻。我再怎么钦佩你也不为过。不，这太棒了。而且有那种雄心壮志，说到这个，杰森，你知道，他明天要去开球，打18洞，然后要在跑步机上跑六英里。我的意思是，那也是雄心壮志。
And I might hit a half bucket of balls after. I mean, that's ambition as well. It's a lot. And Sean... You never played golf back in the day, right? This is relatively new, right, Jason? Well, no, I started when I was 18, but then I stopped for a long time. Oh, you did?
而且我之后可能会打半桶球。我的意思是，那也是雄心壮志。这很多。还有肖恩……你以前从不打高尔夫球，对吧？这是相对较新的，对吧，杰森？嗯，不，我18岁时就开始了，但后来停了很长时间。哦，你停了？
Wow, I felt like when we first met, you were not like Will was obsessed with golf and you didn't play. Is that not true? I think I had stopped for a while. Then Will got me back in during COVID. By the way, real quick, the best thing in this, I think in the smartest thing is that like, who was the guest? And he's like, Jason, didn't you win that like Formula One race?
哇，我觉得我们刚认识的时候，你不像威尔那样沉迷于高尔夫，而且你不打球。不是这样吗？我想我停了一段时间。然后威尔在新冠期间让我重新开始了。顺便说一句，快点，我觉得这里最棒、最聪明的事情是，嘉宾是谁？他说，杰森，你不是赢了那场一级方程式赛车吗？
And you're like, yeah, yeah, I did. Like what? No, he's one of the... It was a cheesy celebrity race. Talk about the sassan guy who can do anything. No, but it's Jason, please. It's like, it's like just admit your power. So it's true.
然后你说，是啊，是啊，我赢了。像什么？不，他是其中之一……那是一场俗气的名人赛。谈谈那个什么都能做的萨桑人。不，但这是杰森，拜托。这就像是，承认你的力量吧。所以这是真的。
It's like, dude, he fucking won a Formula One race. It wasn't Formula One. Badly, Badly, not only didn't do that, it was the Long Beach Grand Prix thing and he did that. And then recently he goes... You won the whole thing. No, he won. And then recently we're talking about a golf tournament.
就像，伙计，他他妈赢了一场一级方程式赛车。那不是一级方程式。布莱德利，布莱德利，不仅没做过那个，那是长滩大奖赛之类的，他做了那个。然后最近他说……你赢了整个比赛。不，他赢了。然后最近我们在谈论一个高尔夫锦标赛。
We're talking about a different golf tournament. The Bob Hope River, he goes, yeah, I won that twice out of this one. What do you mean you won it? What are you talking about, dude? I know. What are you talking about? This is Bradley's time. It's really true.
我们在谈论另一个高尔夫锦标赛。鲍勃·霍普河，他说，是啊，我赢了两次。你赢了是什么意思？你在说什么，伙计？我知道。你在说什么？这是布莱德利的时间。这确实是真的。
Sean, Sean got... Here we come. Right, you got the best customer ever at Shaky's Pizza. Whatever it was. Right? A million miler, they said. A million miles of pizza. You ate a million miles of pizza.
肖恩，肖恩得到了……我们来了。对，你在Shaky's Pizza得到了有史以来最好的顾客。不管是什么。对吧？他们说，百万英里。一百万英里的披萨。你吃了一百万英里的披萨。
Just impressive. That's it. Oh, man. Bradley, you get fired and get out of here and come hang out. Come on. All right. That's enough already. You have to fire himself.
真是令人印象深刻。就是这样。天哪。布莱德利，你被解雇了，快离开这里，过来玩吧。来吧。好了。已经够了。你得自己解雇自己。
Bradley, thank you, man. Bradley, thank you, everybody. Love you, pal. Love you, buddy. Guys, thank you, buddy. Thank you for this. Love you. What an honor.
布莱德利，谢谢你，伙计。布莱德利，谢谢大家。爱你，伙计。爱你，哥们。伙计们，谢谢你们，哥们。谢谢你们做的一切。爱你。真是荣幸。
Thank you. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you, buddy. Great. Perfect guest for 100 episodes.
谢谢。爱你。爱你。爱你。爱你。爱你，哥们。太棒了。100集的完美嘉宾。
And like I said at the end, he feels like family. So it was a perfect idea. I know. I know. That's what I thought. We need to have somebody that we all know and that there's history and family that we had on. And of course it was wild that we hadn't had Bradley.
就像我最后说的那样，他感觉像家人一样。所以这是一个完美的主意。我知道。我知道。我也是这么想的。我们需要找一个我们都认识的人，而且有历史和家庭渊源的人。当然，我们还没请过布莱德利真是太疯狂了。
We had him on the tour, but, you know. And just so generous to be so honest and open with knowing that it ain't just us three, you know, kicking around and having old times. But I love chit chats like that because how many people that helps, how many people relate to it. If you're having similar issues that you can relate to somebody even like Bradley Cooper, who's going through the same thing as anybody else. So it normalizes it.
我们请他参加过巡演，但是，你知道。而且他非常慷慨，如此诚实和开放，知道这不仅仅是我们三个人，你知道，闲逛和叙旧。但我喜欢那样的聊天，因为这帮助了多少人，多少人能产生共鸣。如果你有类似的问题，你可以和像布莱德利·库珀这样的人产生共鸣，他正在经历和任何人一样的事情。所以这使它正常化了。
That's a constant process. But it's the ability to actually connect with yourself and be able to go and Bradley has, and I mean, and you guys have noticed it too. We talked about, you know, he has done a lot of work and he's, you know, and we know other people have too in our lives and we have members of our family and ourselves who we talk about these things all the time about being in touch with where we're at and what's going on and being honest with yourself and what's great is Bradley. Self-aware.
这是一个持续的过程。但这是真正与自己连接并能够去做的能力，布莱德利做到了，我的意思是，你们也注意到了。我们谈到了，你知道，他做了很多工作，而且他，你知道，我们也知道其他人也做了，在我们的生活中，我们有家庭成员和我们自己，我们一直在谈论这些事情，关于了解我们所处的位置和正在发生的事情，并对自己诚实，最棒的是布莱德利。自我意识。
Yeah. And that self-awareness comes from being honest about where you're at. And, you know, I think that I love that stuff. I can talk all day about the, you know, the idea of whatever it is you are, whatever story it is you decide to tell about yourself. Fucking people love getting hung up on their story. They love it. They love it.
是啊。那种自我意识来自于对自己所处位置的诚实。而且，你知道，我想我喜欢那些东西。我可以整天谈论，你知道，无论你是什么的想法，无论你决定讲述关于你自己的什么故事。他妈的人们喜欢沉迷于他们的故事。他们喜欢它。他们喜欢它。
They love it. It's the whole idea and they go, and also like that goes for the future too. If you're talking about, well, you know, shit's going to be really hard. And it's all you can decide. And for more information, check out my Instagram stories. Yeah. Sorry. I forgot to keep driving people to your socials.
他们喜欢它。这就是整个想法，他们说，而且这也适用于未来。如果你在谈论，嗯，你知道，事情会变得非常困难。而这正是你能决定的。欲了解更多信息，请查看我的Instagram故事。是啊。抱歉。我忘了继续引导人们去你的社交媒体了。
If you want to see Sean and Scotty high in their living room dancing to commercials. Look, that's the story we tell ourselves. That's the story we're telling. Sean and Scotty on a gummy. The way we did last night. But truly this, this 100 thing is a real, a real, like I'm surprised every time I, that we have a podcast. Like, I'm like, Oh, this podcast tomorrow.
如果你想看肖恩和斯科蒂在客厅里嗑药，随着广告跳舞。看，这就是我们告诉自己的故事。这就是我们正在讲述的故事。肖恩和斯科蒂嗑了软糖。就像我们昨晚做的那样。但说真的，这100集的事情是一个真正的，真正的，就像我每次想到我们有一个播客时都很惊讶。就像，我心想，哦，明天有这个播客。
Like, I can't believe we do a podcast. I can't do that. I hope I never get used to it. Because it stays as soon as it's like, Oh yeah, that's so great. We get to go do that. So thank you everybody for letting us do this. Like, not only do we get to connect with our friends like Bradley, but we get to meet new people that we don't know.
就像，我不敢相信我们做了一个播客。我做不到。我希望我永远不会习惯它。因为它保持着，一旦它像，哦，是的，那太棒了。我们有机会去那样做。所以谢谢大家让我们做这件事。就像，我们不仅有机会与像布莱德利这样的朋友联系，而且我们还有机会结识我们不认识的新朋友。
And we get to kind of pick their brain. And hopefully we're asking some of the questions you want asked. And you keep listening. We'll keep doing it. Yes. It means just the world to us. So thank you. Thank you for listening.
我们有机会去探究他们的想法。希望我们问了一些你想问的问题。只要你们继续听，我们就会继续做下去。是的。这对我们来说意味着全世界。所以谢谢。谢谢你们的收听。
Thank you for being there. And I'm so grateful that you give us the opportunity to do it. So thank you. A big genuine sincere. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And I'll see you next time.
谢谢你们的支持。我非常感谢你们给了我们机会去做这件事。所以谢谢。一个巨大的、真诚的、诚挚的。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。下次见。
The tallest, most bold capital letters of. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
最高、最大胆的大写字母。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。